donc ils en sont aux premiers matches là
ils sont en train de jouer leurs prix la
partie bon pour les mots on dirait que
séance et s'est pas tu lèves là disons
qu'avec le roi au centre ça devrait être
pas top pour consigne très bientôt fallu
donc on verra ce qui se passera
donc oui poussé f4 c'est clairement une
bonne décision pour pour aller au f5
plus d'un je pense qu'il ya des grosses
mais là c'est donc la lac aux cygnes au
quai quasiment obligés d'aller en effet
et après il y aura quand même des f-5
peut-être qu'il faut problème 5 allait
prendre d'un prend il ya un fou prend
6,6 à la fin donc ça a l'air salaires et
c'est dangereux
un album il est parti ce qu'un chien en
ok ok donc on 18 sommes pareilles on
peut risquer ouais comme une dame bassin
par exemple ça a l'air d'être pas mal
qu'est ce qu'il aurait pu faire d'autres
peut-être même au juste à 5
comme on avait dit après sur faut
prendre qu à l epr en appareils à la fin
il y aura foule francis salève asiri ce
qu'ils ont fait mais bon du coup la pas
faire il a fait qu'elle est la fedama 5
donc je vois pas trop son idée avec
damas cinq membres est ce qu'elle veut
faire
j'imagine qu'elle doit en avoir une
autre idée telle qu'il veut faire des
carriers bessette offrant des avantages
du cloud âge mais ça va pas là très
nocif parce que sur quelle est cette
dame
ouah c'est 8 le kavé il sera forcé de
repartir donc ok donc pour l énorme ont
pris hockey l'a repris et c'est vrai que
c'est combien km2 continue pour une
europe qui doit pousser sacrifie h
quatre entraînements mais ça ça va être
difficile
donc juste pour un petit rappel donc là
c'est sa selle les appariements
ok donc est ce qui se passait
ok hkb 4è food et zinc
ouais donc à la des petites chances avec
une heure c'est vrai c'est vrai mais on
a eu 2 il doit y avoir des choses
peut-être même poussé b6 b5 b6 même ça
ça peut aller
je vous dise on met 5 6 et si elle prend
en un g2 alors peut-être b6 sur apprend
alors à ce moment là il y aura il y aura
damas huit donc ça devrait quand même
haye est désolé si vous avez émis des
commentaires du coup là j'ai pas pu voir
les blés pour les premiers commentaires
juin juste d'ouvrir la ''charte savais
que je les passe à mon ordi j'ai juste
mon portable vous voulez commenter à
précédents ne sont pas ne sont pas
visibles du coup voici les 10
commentaires désolé désolé c'était pas
fait il serait de vous ignorer
du coup vous pouvez remettre les
commentaires si jamais un jamais vous
affirmez que vous effet ignoré
ok donc le temps commence à couler
minutes chacune si si ça l'a pas mal
ouais sur d'armes prend aussi il y aura
toujours ses seins je pense qu'ils
devraient gagner c'est à l'air vraiment
vraiment top
et donc si la dame par on a je crois
bien sûr urmatt
on sait c'est donc là il n'y a pas
beaucoup de choix il ya juste un truc
entre dames ceci ces boîtes dame si vite
c'est possible mais ça va pas l'air de
bien entretenir non plus hier en tête
des qualifs des six aussi sur sa sur la
dame rouge qu'elle est premier set
utilisant le le clouage même cas et
francs à cette peut-être c'est possible
à oui dams et 8-k les prendre à 7
la dame bougé après on va sur damour
compte cinq et ses échecs et après la
tour est obligé de défendre et ça marche
pas parce que là du coup le tueur va
reprendre ou alors même voix même temps
de 16 aces
du coup il a tenté sa maman après
qu'elle ait prendre un set c'est plutôt
fini mais c'est vrai que si elle voit
paquet pour un set tout peut arriver
encore si elle jouait entre comme cai
des six alors là elle peut quand même
essayer de se battre
il ya juste il ya seulement calais
pendant sept ans baltique qui finira
partie parce que c'est là c'est le seul
qui menace d'un grand dessein et carrick
et chaque
ah ah bah c'est pas du coup la fesse à
rendre ok donc à l'aller pour la ligne
la plus la plus simple donc elle avait
voulu changer les pièces et après je
pense qu'elle va gagner ce assez
facilement mais faut quand même du coup
faire gaffe aux menaces des mort parce
qu'avec ce pur hk ça a l'air super fort
du coup faut quand même qu'elle fasse
gaffe au kef un geste rue comme oui donc
là il peut même plus faire des maîtres
cinq échecs et sait pas c'est pas facile
car ça ne sera pas facile de gagner
ah bah du coup à je croise à l'aide
ouais elle peut cacher son grand âge 2
ça c'est bien ça c'est top
ouais mais ça va être pas tant que ça
finalement il y aura des cas légers
quartier arrivants
on va du coup ça devrait gagner sans
problème en chef et wes s est jamais
dire jamais mais du coup la calquer un
truc mais ça marchait pas après fou
bodivit coup là il se passe quoi là
ouais donc la bombe ouf a perdu bouton
home mince alors elle a vraiment craqué
à la fin
ouais là bas elle a perdu le goût mumbai
que c'était mieux que gagner c'était un
truc assez surprenant wendel qu'on doit
oui bon du coup je vais vous mettre les
la cub et je vais revenir tout de suite
[Musique]
ok alors je suis de retour donc moi je
stage ajuster les chez qui un peu donc
ça soit bien voilà c'est bien
donc
- du coup ce qui s'est passé c'était
resté une prochaine lors les cavaliers 2
ce qui en fait c'est la ligne bleue joue
avec les banques
donc je connais bien ça c'est d'ailleurs
marrant qu'avec les séquelles et jouer
ça parce que c'est pas très connu mais
c'est ce que je tout le temps au temps
f5 et amis des deux va donc à la femme
qui est là un au pl a fait f3 donc ça ça
c'est typique je crois c'est aussi
possible de faire petit rock
bonjour la loge au petit à petit mais f3
ça va aussi c'est pour ouvrir la colonne
longer donc là elle fait le sacrifice
ouais ouais donc ça c'est normal
donc en gros l'aller les blancs ils ont
ils ont sacrifié en q1 mais c'est pour
abord beaucoup de d'initiatives plus et
là il ya des plus on oublie qu'ils sont
pas top et un les cases noires sont
clairement la faveur des lits des blancs
donc je porte pierre canadiens ont un
petit avantage puisque on dirait qu'elle
a pas hélas pas dessus très bien très
bien je me sens
ça va c'est intéressant ça crie ministre
qu'elle aurait dû le prendre elle aurait
dû prendre en g2 est vraiment sacrifié
sacrifie le pion et du coup ils
l'abordent accepté sacrifices mais du
coup on ne vous entend pas là je pense
que les noirs ont des petits problèmes
il ya quand même un pion de plus de plus
pour les normes et elle aurait pu en
avoir deux de plus donc ça a été un peu
mieux pour elle ok du coup continent
sous se passe sinon la partie donc ok
donc là la tour est attaqué il ya des
menaces donc j'imagine la tour doit
aller en lan 7
car et c'est sale c'est bien faut juste
faire gaffe parce qu'ils aient pas des
menaces du style dame à deux mais on
dirait que dawn 18 ça doit aller mais
d'amadou salaire assez dangereux chez
moi je sais pas si c'est pas super pote
donne des billes toi il ya peut-être des
dames 18 fouet tour f8 à tour prend g7
suivie des tours j'ai ans en l'air
d'aller je pense que ça doit mater nerfs
ouais ça a l'air du mat et du coup et ça
c'est pas possible
donc la dame points à 6 h c'est pour ça
qu'il a joué à six parce qu'elle a envie
de faire demain à 2 c m'annonça et voit
les imiter les dames 18 sep mais c'est
pour ça qu'elle a fait ça bah dis donc
bienvenu 101 bienvenus du coup là une
menace damas en ainsi qu'à vélib est roi
il y aura quatre je pense que l a réussi
à sauver africa a réussi sous là je vois
pas vraiment de choses pour les blancs
c'est l'essai de revenir angers salle
pour faire des dindes 8 sympa vraiment
l'air de marcher sur deux qui aura des
dames ans après le premier de même juste
homme prend b2 qu'est ce que je dis
qu'est ce que je raconte juste d'un pont
en béton d'un prendre mes deux roues à
wade de est d'après vous trouver une
façon de défendre comme ça mais p'tet
que c'est même pas une menace
quoique c'est vraiment pas clair sudoku
il ya quand même une différence
maintenant que la les nordistes ont
poussé à acheter ça change des choses ça
devrait quitter sa paroisse et aussi ça
ça permet de wayne dans certains cas de
oui justement dosé de partir avec
l'europe
donc ouais ok donc elle a créé dam des
mythes sur touré fuite
il y aura un mandat vie quand même tout
proche de celle donc c'est pour ça
qu'elle a fait en rachète c'était bien
vu oui c'est pour ça que le fait d'abord
jouer ainsi ça n'aide vraiment et c'est
vraiment bien vu de savoir alors
bienvenue
donc c'est nul c'était assez assez
prévisible à la fin on va monter que
tout sur
ok donc sar puis on que l'as une
ouverture
voumard ça fait bizarre avec kiev 4 au
premier coup mais en bits c'est pas mal
en plus ça ressemble un peu à une
bouillie sûrement assez classique de 2
commence à s'affiner avec king of kings
ou bien en attaque avec cavaliers 3d
détroit et le film cadeau mais le soldat
seule différence avec l'option ayant
fait quatre bons ça change quand même
pas mal de choses qu'en général le
cavalier toujours devant le champ
ok donc là il ya peut-être du bessin qui
m'arrivait
donc la tête même des cadres sakho reste
hanté
ouais ça c'est bien pour mon a cédé 4
est aussi way empêché quelque chose de
venir au rétro n'a peut-être simplement
prendre mais après on aura la colonne
pour nos tours avec le pion c5 qui peut
être attaqué h3 ça a l'air pas mal aussi
h 3 mai pour chasser ce cavalli nous
embêter après prendre en bessin
ouais il ya le pallium top 5 avec mon
avis telle qu'on peut juste prendre et
après un bon j'ai vraiment envie
d'attaquer ce pion je sais pas comment
le faire ce que si on mêle cavaillon à
troyes il aura le temps de se défendre
une autre kalisa assez mal placé en a
trois du coup un coup ça a pas l'air
d'aller tout de suite ol à fait ok elle
l'a fait mais du coup il ya dame b 6
ouais d'un blessé ça a l'air de bien
tenir et le cabri il assez mal an à 3
donc ouais je sais pas si c'était le
meilleur choix
faut pas me woods est en général quand
j'ai décidé way f5 peut-être ça va mais
au québec six
ouais c'est dans le même esprit mais liu
coup là il y aura peut-être des j'ai
senti mon arrivée
dommage 4 aussi peut-être suivie de la
l5
1 fois 5 ça marche ça marche jamais
parce qu'il ya cavaliers qui défend du
coup la papa sahel et la fête b4 ainsi
intéressant donc bon bien sûr elle peut
pas prendre quand elle peut prendre mais
ça sera en échange de pièces simplement
parce qu'on a ces deux défendeurs donc
oui ça l'est peut-être pas mon vrai donc
elle est quasiment obligé de prendre et
après faut prendre car il prend d'un
point on se retrouvera pas malin
puissions rampillon viser les jambes et
5 le client sera faible en d4 salaires
aux membres dont pas mal est si elle
veut garder les pièces elle peut marquer
un essai de d'ailleurs et prendre avec
lecavalier
ok elle abuse ok super
ouais non non le kabyle était pas qu'il
était très loin de ça
ok donc que ce qui s'est passé ok il
faut prendre donc là je pense qu'elle a
une très bonne position
arica donc bon je pense qu'elle est elle
est clairement femmes dans ce match
parce que déjà la première partie qu'on
a vu cette avance chocques causé new
gagne c'était vraiment incroyable parce
qu'elle est et il a une position
vraiment préférable qu'elle est là
encore elle joue très bien donc ouais on
va m'apporter ce passera mais je dirais
plutôt qu'elle avait créée c'est plutôt
elle qui a des chances après c'est ça
c'est mes chronos tk après je peux je
peux me tromper comme totalement
bon bah du coup à trois coups simples
pour empêcher le faux prend à deux bien
sûr
ouais donc avant aux coups précédents
d'ailleurs je dire qu est menacé les
trucs du genre fous ces cinq aussi bien
sûr ça s'était attaquée donc c'est
toujours attaquer c'est vrai mais un
apparemment elle a choisi de ne pas le
prendre parce que sur faut prendre cette
y avait foule prend 1,2 donc et s'est
dit que c'était pas montrer mon agent je
propose donc là peut-être g5 sur cavalli
et 7 mai à tout va en fait j'essaie de
voir pourquoi faut prendre ça marcherait
pas puisque à non mais pas tout de suite
oui parce qu'il ya ça du coup on fait
d'abord j'ai cinq caves et pons fcf au
premier set
donc les cages et sain et plus non plus
surprise qu'elle et prend le 6 d'un pont
au qu'est ce qu'elle veut faire
c'est bizarre
en tout cas veut juste prendre au jeu en
salle c'est tout
oui d'abord j'ai cinq points mais c'est
ce que je pensais en fait ça m'a l'air
vraiment pas mal mais mais du coup ouais
là et s'est retrouvé dans de saint-cricq
des sacrés problèmes
mouais surprise dès qu'elle peut encore
le sauver
après bon après faut prendre mais ça a
l'air assez compliqué quand même mais
bon ce qui est ce qui la sauve c'est que
le pion et 7 est faible mais qu'elle
peut peut-être le prendre et aussi la
des menaces sur achètent
donc juste pour ceux qui viennent
d'arriver ça c'est
donc ça c'est les joueurs et on en est à
voile contrat que c'est mieux contre
dronneau valley donc on a là et voilà ça
c'est les gagnantes du haut des marches
précédentes donc là il y avait un line
up qui a gagné aussi et biblis à assen
vayer bas donc voilà donc c'est
seulement la première phase c'est une
aura beaucoup plus donc les gagnantes
joueront contre elle ça serait assez
intéressant voilà donc reprenons nos
commentaires ok donc où là qu'est ce qui
s'est passé qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ok donc ça ouais ça a l'air normal mais
le souci pour les blancs c'est qu'il
faut jamais vraiment passé ici et du
coup vu que je dirais qu positionnement
leur position d'apatow surtout après un
échange de dames
mais c'est vrai que il ya quand même un
peu on fait le monde les 5 qui peut être
attaqué lisons sur les changes dam d'un
français 8 pourquoi en tête on peut
faire des tourbillons pas rater quelques
médecins qui essaient de me de se
focaliser là dessus toi oui toi yifan
favorite ça c'est ça c'est sûr ça c'est
sûr ouais c'est clairement la plus forte
enfin sur le sur le papier en tout cas
même même sens fin novembre sa force de
jeu est bien supérieure aux autres bien
sûr mais bon tout peut arriver vu que
j'avais vu que c'est du bisse français
c'est pas forcément comme les échecs
classique donc on sait jamais si ça
trouve il y en a des frissons plus forte
en bits
ouais donc là je dirais que c'est déjà
un avantage pour les blancs il ajuste un
coup c'est le pion peut-être qu'ils
oxylane ya le pion f4 qui tombe depuis
ont des quatre aussi va être faibles
salaires roman
donc faut voir je suis tisser qui
viendra la course
ça va tellement vite aulas c'est le
grand jeu pour les deux donc là je pense
que faut faire retour à chang'e 3 et
après sacrifions la tour alors sacrifier
la dame pardon et après revenir avec nos
armes est du coup assez similaire à ce
qu'elle a fait wade du coup là il nous
reste juste à prendre le pion mais après
elle s'en sortir après roy g3 elles
restent à prendre
d'accord je vais phaléne ike avait eu
deux mondes du combat je suis assez
fière qu'elle joue ça m'a vexé la maline
je pensais que personne n'a joué ccc
malines fétis pas ce qu avait lieu de du
coup alliot marie france corre et arica
va essayer de jouer quelque chose
d'autre oh la la partipation je crois
que la veille et non est là elle avait
pris y en a quatre et après ça a été ça
qui a été jouée je crois hélas prix donc
là je pense qu'elle va essayer de
changer
ouais ben achour j'irai donc ça c'est
des positions qu'ils ont quittée en
paiement moins drôle à jouer après 1,5
après il faut jouer à trois des trucs du
genre simplement amusant
ouais donc là c'est un peu fermé donc là
j'imagine va essayer de faire déjà
quelque peu même temps tdf sein du
pouvoir ouvrir le jeu mais bon ça c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment trop bas et sur
toute la cub un parc ou cegeka donc
assez là c'est le moment
du coup la bonne manoeuvre pensée de m
carrie angers 5 ouest il faut prendre
après m'être la dame l'a pourchassé
lecavalier a pressé de sortir son propre
canal
moi je dirais que la même plus fin c'est
même beaucoup plus que carlson parce
qu'un seul il ya quand même des gens qui
sont proches de lui alors que vous ayez
fans avaient elles ont peu au dessus du
lot ouais c est là encore plus bas
seront pareillement elle est encore plus
forte que carlson dupont simon l'a
comparé aux autres aux autres humains
mais bon avant il y avait paul garde
bien sûr on peut garer été carrément
cédant 1 dans une autre est sur une
autre planète comparé aux autres mines
paul garret l'été un choix qui a été de
même dans le top 10
mik donc ouais mais bien sûr enfin
l'arrêté douid on la commente pas mais
bien sûr au pôle gare était bien plus
forte que confier je voulais je dirais
que c'est déjà un gros avantage pour les
normes parce qu'il y aura des c5 qui
vont arriver peut-être aussi à 5 du
salaire aussi d'être passif pas si grave
peut-être prendre mais après pousser mes
5 c'est peut-être possible ou alors
simplement prendre et faire d'autres
choses pas la peine de pousser mais ça
mais bon ça me tente dans le gard à elle
a hélas pas fait elle avait tout faux
c'est bizarre donc là ça donne en plus
l'avantagé par parce que ça lui laisse
prendre et pousser et pousse et ça c'est
ça ou attaque ça donne le temps non
ouais donc là elle a réfléchi longtemps
touré feat c'est bizarre j'ai aucune
idée de ce que j'ai vu jouer avec ce
pool
si l'as trouvé le juste poussé et 6 mais
c'est super bizarre d'avoir vu ça ça pas
trop de sens toile du coup là il faut
juste faire ça après elle aurait pu
pousser fait cinq ou six comme l'a dit
caméra catois pas ce que veut faire et
se couvre
elle veut juste empêcher ces cinq mais
du coup il aurait pu l'empêcher en
faisant des cinq albums
je pense que ça aurait été lé sort et
eliokem a-il dit tyrol quoi tu as raison
ouais il dit qui rock tu as besoin
la raison om manon
du coup c'est sale c'est pas possible
mais elle prépare son tour ses 8 et
c'est quand même une grosse menace
bon vieux coup là il y aura 5 à mon avis
ou alors même b5
c'est l'heure d'aller aussi
juste pour le petit rappel ça c'est le
format de jeu donc il ya seize joueuses
en tout il ya donc lui invité donc c'est
ça c'est pour ceux qui n'ont pas encore
suivi le ce qui se passait donc vous
avez toutes les informations là
du coup c'est quoi vos pronostics alors
qui est ce qu'il vous pensez qui va
gagner
alex song ok c'est vrai qu'elle a il
mène déjà elle mène donc c'est vrai quel
avantage psychologique pour nom est bon
je dirais que arica a quand même à
entrer meilleure performance cependant
je trouve que là et là on peut mieux
jouer mais même si elle a perdu les
parties bien sûr là bas et il y en plomb
en or
il n'avait pas bien niveau sports ons
mais je trouve qu'elle appelle un peu
des meilleures parties que peu plus et
mieux pour le mans donc on sait pas mais
c'est vrai qu'elle craque un peu à la
fin sous la pression et elle craque
katia way katia saleh s'était c'était
très intense son match que la fée la
dernière fa contrat contre goulinat
c'était c'était fou mais je pourrais
bien que dès qu'elle peut gagner vrai au
mois du coup je miserais tests sur l'eau
bouillie fans mais c'est mais c'est vrai
que je sais pas comment ils jouent en
bits donc de mon jeu je sais pas
enthousiasmé bas elle pas vraiment si à
trop il y aura lieu une autre qui sera
largement meilleur on its way là là je
pense que ces gros avantage pour pour
alexandra déjà parce qu'elle va faire
des têtes des cavaliers h 3 kg 5
pour essayer de 2
replacé le cavalier est aussi là pour à
700 l'air pas mal
voire même tour à 6 tours b 6 pour asi
cessé de taper le cul en double et ce
fut les deux tours comme ça on essaie de
prendre l'avion j'ai donc c'est un sale
fils de [ __ ]
donc on peut juste 3 prendre je pense
annonce est pas totalement
s'affaiblissent mais du coup là il ya
quand même quelques points de st
donc c'est comme si c'était enfin du
coup je pense qu'elle n'a pas de ça en
fait ouais elle a pas du voir ça en a
besoin elles sont installées çà c'est
une grosse gaffe way et arica fait
vraiment trop gaffe ça ça lui coûtera
beaucoup le pensent c'est ouais c'est
dommage pour elle mais du coup alexandre
est du coup je retire ce que j'ai dit je
retire totalement ce que j'ai dit du
coup alexandre a gagné donc là c'est un
gros avantage niveau score déjà 3 contre
11 ça sera difficile de 2,2 d'augmenter
surtout que si arica déjà des problèmes
avec le temps aux baléares s'est dit bis
quand la cadence descendra ça sera
encore plus plus plus difficile pour
elle donc marcher mon coeur ok donc là
ils ont arrêté la partie parce que
apparemment c'est la pause
donc il y aura une petite pause je pense
que ça durera cinq minutes
savent pas abandonner ouais c'est le mr
power
bon du coup il y aura lie à la pause là
du coup comme vous pouvez voir le times
le temps s'est arrêté
donc on attendra qu'elle reprenne
bon du coup je vais je vais faire une
petite pause moi aussi et je verrai
du coup je reviens dans dans quelques
minutes
elles vont reprendre la prochaine partie
donc juste pour le rappel l'aï et les 35
minutes
en fait c'est qu'une fois qu'elles se
sont écoulés ça voudra dire que ça sera
l'heure de partir en 3 + 2 donc là pour
le nom c'est la cadence 5 + 2 et après
ça fasse comme 3 + 2 et après la fin ça
sera du bullet c'est comme ça que ça
marche et sans information assez
intéressant le trou donc voilà ok a tout
de suite
[Musique]
ça y est bien de reprendre
du coup voyons voir ce qu'il soit donc
cette fois ci nuit câline noir et un
jean louis c'est tout vert folle donc si
une ouverture anglaise c'est assez bon
ils appellent ça la ligne symétrique
parce que jusque-là cgc symétrique mais
pas vraiment en fait c'est pas vraiment
symétrique mais bon ça s'appelle la dda
symétrique je ne sais pas pourquoi
fo demandé au créateur de l'ouverture
mais bon du coup là il ya des petits
plans comme comme b4 pas par exemple ou
alors ouais ou alors peut-être peut-être
faire des caries j'ai cinq ou six dans
certains cas même on n'a pas trop envie
de prendre donc elle a bien empêcher ces
cas les g5 donc là qui agissent 5
c'était juste pour prendre la plus le
fou aux six en cas de bessens que ça
peut être dangereux parce que du coup le
cas lecavalier sera faible
elle sera attaqué par le fou n'a
peut-être des fous ou trois c'est
possible b4 on en aimerait bien le faire
mais ça va mieux
il ya vraiment trop de pièces ils
défendent nous faut oublier cette idée
ok il a quand même fait je pensais que
ça se jouait pas mais apparemment ça
joue donc donc s'il prend il le cavalier
ah bah oui le plus mauvais sens qu'il
est il est peut attaquer il et il n'est
pas protégé ok donc en fait c'est
possible look est donc allé prendre b4
et à quel point les 5
il est sinon sur vous en met 4 mois je
pense que sur fou prend mes 4 et à ce
moment là il y avait qu à vie prend 1,5
et sur france 3 y attaquer et princesses
donc ouais et 6 baies 5
ok ça a l'air assez assez normal damas
quatre salles impossible donc le pion
aux oeufs de vue défendu par le cavalier
même prendre en d4 peut être andré
qu'avec mes impressions avec le cavalier
qu'il reprenne avec l'appui en haute
kabylie notre cahier c3 aura des
problèmes il faudrait qu'ils bougent s
ils bougent en quatre il sera chassé au
le parle plus d'ailleurs je pense qu'il
sera perdue après calais prend des 40
reprend le cahier dé cape iv pas ce
moment là il aurait 5
donc ouais faut pas faire ça du coup
damas quatre à homs alors
donc c'est bien ce qu'elle a joué faux
détroit est maintenant way to excellence
est normal pour occuper la colonne aussi
notre fou un tacle le pion mais c'est
donc la tour est un peu forcé de
défendre c'est pas forcément tomtom donc
de trois on aimerait bien faire mais la
femme qui est curieux y aura du monde et
3 il est sera faible on n'en faut voir
si ça marche
à mon avis c'est juste risqué de
d'affaiblir son option peut-être fou et
3 pour essayer d'échanger se fout c'est
peut-être possible fallu 3 ou alors pour
ces deux peut-être faut essayer de
doubler sur la colline c'est ok d'am-dam
ces deux donc ce qu'elle voulait faire
avec ce goût a donc elle voulait
défendre d'être donc va me pousser le 3
c'est donc ça ah oui et vous aussi v3
est sûre sur fouquet et si ça veut faire
cavalier cabale ira 4c m'annonce un
malin way et du coup là si les noirs
font rien du tour qui aura vraiment ce
étroit et après callas 4 et le fou sera
assurée par du hockey
donc peut-être se défendre avec l idée 5
mais ça ne change pas grand-chose sur
enfin c'est juste que ça les change le
calme mais ça va être parfait a molli
nord mais à quoi peut être que kerry des
500 me
bon ça les change tout donc maintenant
les leroy est le rock est un peu faible
mais c'est pas vraiment en gros ceci je
dirais que stratégiquement là qu ils
sont un peu préférable poids pour les
blancs sont toutes là quand la tour est
au plus mal passé en 2007 il y aura
aussi surtout des idées sur le sur le
pion à 7 plus tard donc on dirait que à
cause la structure d'accueil ont géré
que là c'est un peu mieux faut pour les
blancs sous la halle et tous ses pions
là sont assez bien bien défendu le cube
et ça a été le cas cette fois voir des
femmes la fiom et 5 aussi peut avoir des
preuves mais c'est juste en plomb alors
que là il y avait quand même devions qui
sont faites pour les noirs et surtout la
tour peut aussi rentrer un peu plus
rapidement mais bon du coup ce qui se
passera j'imagine d'impro tout reprend
après il y aura des tours c'est 8
j'imagine donc la tour ses entours
penser car après tout reprend ses quatre
donc la date la tour sera la dernière la
tour blanche aura le contrôle de la
commune s'est donc imagine lina seront
obligés de faire des trucs du genre fou
b6 pour essayer d'empêcher la tour
d'aliens d'alliance et 7 mai ok donc
elle accepte ce qu'elle ait et les
opales à coups de la colonne c'est donc
là ce moment là il y aura vraiment des
tours 7
un peu plus tard parce que pour ça ça te
taper fou v6 du coup qu'est ce que j'ai
fait avec ça quelques pouces et 8 6
ouais et beaucoup de ces pays je pense
donc je vais voir si je pars c'est
surtout que c'est sa compote sur ces 7
c'est qu'il y avait peut-être qu'ils
avaient faux mais si tu m'as fait
surtout recette va pas vraiment un coup
droit et fuite il ya les fous bekaert du
coc a peut-être qu'il y avait juste il y
avait deux tours 8
ouais ok pour échanger les tours mais du
coup après lioret l'échangé et leur
calme le contrôle d'akon c'est ouais
mais yo pou x 5 ces crimes bien bien
plus
bernière ouais tu vois c'est quand même
bien meilleure donc la l1 est un énorme
lampion isolé donc des plantes peuvent
essaie de mettre la pression tu veux
mais c'est pas si facile surtout que
c'est une finale deux tours qui sont
assez égal en général donc ce sera
clairement pas simple
le plan des groupes cdg angeli tour pour
faire valoir le pion passé isolés et
éloignés
alors oui oui oui parce que c'est vrai
que là il est seulement faibles parce
qu'il ya des tours qui l'attaquent
c'est vrai que si les noirs arrivent à
échanger les tours et qui se retrouvent
dans une filiale de roi alors là ça
puisse conclure ce piola serait un pion
passé plutôt qu'il est rempli de lit ça
sera vraiment passé il sera vraiment
très dangereux c'est vrai donc tu as
raison mais ça sera plus difficile de le
faire un de le faire marcher dans une
partie parce que là du coup les les
tours sont vraiment en train de
l'attaqué illégale droit qui va passer
en d4 peut-être l'eau tout peut aussi
venir faire des soucis là donc la
croix-des-gardes ça va bouger va cause 2
tours 4
donc là faudra faire roi des trois
j'imagine mais le web du coup c'est pas
clair du coup ça va vraiment pas clair
le pion baissier s'y attaquer donc dès
que les noirs sont obligés de le
défendre
ou alors ils peuvent juste le sacrifier
sa place à ben ouais peut-être par
exemple pour moi f7 donc surtout reprend
b6 y aurait toujours des cinq ouais ça
c'est possible aussi
donc là les femmes c'est toujours ça
serait faire par exemple ici une
fonction des tours aussi ça apaise 7 pas
guillon bien sûr c'est totalement nul
totalement nul donc aulas et c'est ce
qu'elle a fait bizarre
peut-être que je pense que ces gagnants
c'est fou à le peut-être qu'elle voulait
juste homme enlevé les le contrôle des
normes well voulait enlever le contrôle
jeudi noir ouais ok ok donc elle voulait
juste faire nul ouais vous le payez mais
elle continue sa 5e revers des comptines
et ça non mais c'est faux ça et en plus
elle fait au royal st non mais je pense
que et doit avoir les nerfs contre
compte tenu qu au nom ok mon bras
c'était marrant ça ok donc avant l on
fait nul c'était assez c'est assez
logique
donc il ya des gens anglais ok do you
speak of wine catalogue mais du coup là
on va essayer de garder le stream en
france allait du coup je ne
malheureusement pour je ne pourrais pas
répondre en anglais pas ok donc la cinor
après ça sera un pion isolé en d4
oh mais c'est pas forcément une mauvaise
eau mauvaise version toutes options mais
cm et 70 un coup et non je pense que
laïque devrait pendre moi si j'avais les
nerfs je pense que je prendrai pour
essayer ensuite de taper sur le sont les
pions sont l'appui en d4
donc là peut-être sur rock plutôt que de
prendre simplement tête du rock essaie
de passer la tour essaient de faire des
choses rapidement qu'elle a fait j'ai on
dirait que j'ai un don de 2 de deviner
ses coûts
ok donc la lie ok bien sûr y'a plus de
tours et lyon je pense qu'elle va
simplement prendre
hélas après essaie de faire décaler ses
trois fous et 3 pour défendre ses pions
oh bien sûr des cinq là ça marche pas je
pense qu'il y aura simplement qu'elle
prend des saints qui sur d'un prend y
aura fouest et la dame sera perdue
ok donc là ce qui peut arriver ça des
tours en défaut de 5 mais je pense que
là déjà à cause du pic de l'esa sera
peut-être plus facile à je vais pour les
noirs parce qu'ils ont un but vraiment
de taper sur son pion mais du couple est
collé
ouais surtout quand je dirais qu'on a en
plus isolé on aime bien avoir peut-être
cette cette diagonale qui peut qui peut
être utile 10 ans avec un foie en c2 et
une dame en d3 mais là ça vraiment
bloqué donc je pense que c'est pas une
bonne version du père isolé
et puis mentor english winzeler michael
shannon by doing la chase en est avec
cheminée vaudou frenchy mike shannon son
équipe on ne s'est pas tout chaque data
tiugan est d'accueillir agout just right
thing that and you can find smieder
ville de sya des six maillots des 6
miles and i'm so you think you can dance
ok donc là peut-être mon amour bien
faire des dames f3 peut-être détour d un
pour un
mais c'est vrai que c'est il faut ont
l'air assez dangereux donc là je dirais
presque que c'est déjà avantage pour les
noirs parce que c'est difficile en plus
de force puis on est totalement bloquée
il est y aura des fous des six aussi
peut-être même ainsi si les veneurs bon
bein je ne devais changer mais je pense
pas qu'ils ont envie ici
ouais ça a l'air vraiment pas top
donc sur dame et royaux ratures ont
acheté ou alors aussi à 6 pour juste en
chasser tout l'y faut pour aller faire
rentrer à la maison
peut-être y a un coût et drôle là c'est
fait se fout et 7
elle l'a pas fait ok donc choisi de
garder richesse mais du coup c'est une
tête même des sacrifices moi je crois ce
qui serait assez assez drôle mais je
pense que ça doit marcher en plus de
5100 h3 suivi de cavalli g4 peut-être ou
alors simplement prends moi je crois
d'abord quel g4 caillage quatre salaires
bas salaires à ses 1 assez dangereux si
à troubat vraiment le faire donc une ça
l'a fait oula donc prise d'un cran ouais
et donc j'imagine leur devoir faire
grève quatre premiers sets se défendre à
mettet qu'au ciel prend elle est déjà
perdue en fait t'es qu'il ait pas et est
qu'il doit pas prendre tel qu'il est
déjà perdue après ça c'est fou ouais
c'est vrai en plus à l'accord j'avais 8
ans je parle je parle est vraiment mais
même même quand j'étais plus jeune que
ça d'ailleurs
je pense que j'ai dû commencer à 50,6
ont vu que mon père américain bon
j'avais j'ai déjà entendu ça tout le
temps la maison
voilà bah ouais ouais ouais chez moi je
suis plus fort que paul garraud je suis
comme alpha diallo moi moi aimons
stockfisch qui madame a trouvé l'écho
non je rigole bien sûr c'est j'ai aussi
la 2e prix je suis pas c'est pas moi
bien sûr qui barre et qui voient tous
les goûts c'est un stockfisch matin
sinon sinon je pourrais je pourrais
aussi vous vous dire que comme un fan un
peu dansé pendant des heures mais manger
j'essaie quand même deux de faire des
commentaires assez précis donc voilà
donc ex naoki mme balent chinois bon a
malheureusement je ne comprends pas trop
ce que je me raconte mais voilà et si le
cd beau caractère en tout cas lots extra
ahoueya radle oui j'en faisais beaucoup
c'est pas mal de france et pas loin de
chez moi d'ailleurs c'est à ça à 45
kilomètres je crois de filles et moi
donc voilà si on veut parler japonais
mais japonais on peut toujours parler tu
peux tu veux continuer il n'y a pas de
souci
attendre mais tu as compris en fait on
tapait la traduction est ce que dsk est
ce que vous parlez japonnais mois
ouais donc là je dirais que c'est quand
même super chaud à jouer donc là j'ai
imaginé roi et où la paf et sort donc
emmener le roi au centre je pense que ça
va être assez dangereux mais surtout il
ya jusqu'à les 1re cat vous prend pour
même un peu lassé cripia 1,8
on peut même la sa gries parce que sur
fou prend il y aura tout reprend encore
donc ouais ça va être ça mais vous savez
tout mais qui va le tenir
ouais c'est de 7 200 moi aussi je parle
je parle de japonais de google phone 7
je parle d'ailleurs toutes les langues
de boulmiougou france y est
et je parle même mes propres langues que
j'avance
aux dons qu'elle a réussi à se cacher le
droit à la russie c'est fou ça donc
ouais donc comme son adversaire la lueur
est bien juste donner des échecs pour
pouvoir passer leurs robes
donc c'était une bonne nouvelle est
assez sympa de la part de deux amériques
a donné ses 120 $ ca fai afin donc là je
dirais qu'elle a quand même réussi à
survivre il faut faire des cavaliers
leucate avec abel de 4,3 l'air bien ok
l'a pas fait donc l échange les dom donc
en échange et d'hommes ça devrait être
dans sa faveur parce qu'elle a quand
même elle n'a qu'à une pièce de plus mal
et nord où beaucoup de pioncer sait pas
que c'est pas clair puis s contre 2
contre trois quand c'est pas clair à sa
place j'aurais plutôt fait des caves et
de quatre
même là ça peut encore ce tentet
d'ailleurs payé 400 me rappelle à ses
eaux noires de jeu et après il va pas
prêt le court ouais donc d'un t5
bien vu pour l'empêcher elle veut cacher
son rang en b1
aubade ouais je sais pas il devait y
avoir entre gamins mer on peut revenir
un peu un peu avant mais du coup la
l'écoutent les coups ils vont tellement
vite
si on revient on va tout louper donc ici
bon du coup lors ddcs france et trois à
gagner il faut prendre ces trois b prend
dame j'ai deux roues à détroit et d'un
protêt cinq ans mais parce que le plus
le fou bessin écoutons tout ça pour ça
c'est pour ça voilà donc c'était gagnant
mais fallait voir le colloque coup de
fouet des symptômes est donc ce n'était
pas si facile à voir après comme l'a
fait qu'elle ait pas et qu'on l'a fait
qu'à l'époque efficaces étaient déjà non
c'était pas nul non wasa hockey idée il
a changé d'avis dit qu'après dans des
cartes sim hockey et d'ailleurs il a
bien mon sacrifice de tours là en huit
idem bien mais il dit que c'est quand
même eu le ok donc vos repas sont donc
là elle a une pièce de plus mais c'est
vraiment pas facile une photo qu'il a
perdu record en plus un record en pions
pulse non place et font pente cation ça
commence à être beaucoup salut salut
peter la cdu beats et surtout blahic 10
secondes à la pendule seul c'est
difficilement 18 mois chauds à temps
mais là attendant c'est quelle langue
c'est d'une malaisie en tête où on chez
moi
ou alors tu me parle encore japonais
nous où tu t'amuses vient donc bonjour
zaki est donc là je pense que ça aille
mieux quand même hein y'a pas trop de
gaffes possible surtout avec les manque
de temps ou là ou là je découvre ou là
bon ben là c'est clairement c'est
clairement garde noire
j'ai fermé les coups qu'ils voulaient
mais ne voyait pas le félix pour cent
des foyers selon vas-y donc auquel on
n'a clairement garant pour pour un
ricain
elle a d'ailleurs il reste plus qu être
très amplement de 13 min oui donc après
ça ça passera ou trois puces 2 donc ça
sera une cadence un peu plus rapide ça
alors c'est bon c'est quoi non mais
c'est mon bas du coup je peux pas
regarder mais j'ai loupé ça je pensais
que c'était j'ai arrêté rien et je
pensais que c'était archi gagnant pour
pour arica du coup j'ai arrêté de
regarder mais youku ceux qui ont regardé
vous pouvez me dire si sa base et non
mais miller et leur effet tellement
facilement lui fut peut-être bloquer le
roi pour peut pour éviter qu'elles que
ça passe au genre regardez temps je vais
les regarder dans cette partie sous sa
là ça me ça me rend dingue
ben ouais si l on fait nul ici
ok donc ça
[Musique]
ah mais c'est parce qu'elle a pas elle
n'a pas stoppé lyon bat dont vous je
réfléchisse à comment c'est possible a
laissé un trou s'est passé c'est un bon
pote
alors du coup il aurait peut-être pu
faire des tours sa famille a au point b
4 la a6 2,5 chez ben moi je suis nul en
finale du coup du coup j'arrive pas trop
alors à bien savoir mais bon ok du coup
je regarderai ça un peu plus tard mais
ouais ouais c'est archi gagnant mais du
coup je sais pas comment comment gagner
du coup si dans le chat vous savez
comment comment elle aurait pu gagner
dans sa danse est cueilli ce monde va
s'y retrouvent même jeu se faire tour à
sept et après sur ab3 juste pas ses
droits
c'est vrai que le roi et quand mu va
assez vite je le sais pas
ouais non mais il craque toujours craque
toujours
non mais c'était nul à partir d'un
certain moment une fois qu'elle a fait
une gaffe et qu'elle a laissé le roi
passé un peu plus haut un peu plus loin
en loin venu devant l'échiquier ils
disent on attend juste revenir là là je
pense qu'à ce moment là bien sûr cette
j'annule ou aussi là c'est déjà noël
france parce que le royaume est atteint
c'est là ça sera difficile de stopper le
pion mais enfin en fait non on ici
peut-être qu'elle aurait fait tout
récent du hockey bref passons la vente
au sens des cats donne au moins
d'égalité ou noir
ok bah ça fait tu dis tout le monde sait
mais moi j'aime je savais pas du coup tu
parles dame un peu centre des quatre au
noir c'est sa part de au roi noir ou à
la haye non tu parles de cette partie là
tu parles de quoi tu parles de cette
partie là ok ok je pense que tu parle
encore du dollar ou de rapprocher une
partie ok ok ok ok oui du coup là je
suis d'accord avec toi je suis d'accord
il pas ce cahier l'air super il a l'air
super fort ouais
mais c'est pas comme ça mais on continue
qu'elle vient à paris eh bien oui c'est
bien paris
voilà c'est gros avantage gros avantage
pour les normes je pense parce qu'il ya
des fous p3 qui vont arriver et aux 6 et
puis on l'a vu l'air super fort
peut-être y aura aussi des tours 17
tours b 8 et aussi de taper sur le pion
des trois c4 aussi qui est pas arrivé
sarah ouais ouais y'a beaucoup
ouais je ne voulais pas en forme mais
pas en forme américain est d'ailleurs là
il reste plus que 7 minutes et après ça
passera ou trois puces de donc je pense
qu'elle aura encore plus de problèmes
vu qu'elle n'a pas l'air d'être des tops
en en partie le très très rapide donc la
sueur autour des deux il y aura sûrement
qu'à cavalli ce qu'elle et ses gars et
ça marche ou pas non ok c'est katia food
et 500 marche pas fou des cinq échecs
comme intermédiaire le roi bougé après
elle prend un c'est quatre ans à gagner
il faut surtout pas que je fais est
segat nom et mon j'imagine qu'elle ne
jouera pas
alors ça c'est pas leurs lots non c'est
l'inversé les à mai 2006 en échec ça
serait quand même une fille notre
affaire non en vrai en 2005 sans appel
2550 pas d'autres
ouais thales était à ce moment là où tu
joues tu parlais avec la cour tour au
c-2 c'était c'était moins de 1.7 en
point cette femme avait pour les noirs
donc c'était gros avantage mais là un
peu gaffe et on dirait quoique well as
là ici il dit qu'après cas et ces trois
là c est moins 0.4 - 0.04 donc ouais
c'est pas un gros avantage
bayou couler la fenarelle à faire moi
j'ai deux donc donc de nouveaux gros
avantage pour les noirs après fou des
cinq qui menace qu un pib trois fois il
ya quand même une grosse différence
entre entre 2005 et 2006 1
ouais c'est quand même très dur pour les
blancs bien sûr c'est super dur
bah là il leur dit qu après qu a laissé
trois ça sert à égal c'est égal à
nouveau parce qu'elle avait réussi à
sortir ses pièces et du coup là la
position des noirs enfin ils ont
peut-être pas cette pièce pour apprendre
à tailler à prix cassé trois roues
j'imagine qu'il va qu'elle va prendre
après ça il y aura la case de 4 aussi
pour le cavalier salaires des femmes
la pub qui tombe je suis prend des
explications la personne dans le même
temps que tu attends c'est vrai ça
[Rires]
j'aime rappeler ses troupes j'ai fait sa
pub
mais bon les voisins ils font tout le
temps les fronts tout le temps des
travaux donc
donc je me les suis tellement à la pub
ok ok donc ça s'est passé pas ma propre
puce et twitch du bouffey qui fou qui
vous fait ça alors ok
pas loin de mes six ok c'est bien moi
m'a été c était super fort tellement
bonne amie était championne du monde
enfin là j'ai l'impression qu'elle vous
pas trop trop trop activement mais mes
youku à un moment elle était vraiment un
terrain voyez une nette différence au
caire ouais surtout qu'à arica du colis
et l'effort oui en lego rapide va les
aider
clairement forte et en b to c tour trois
tours 3 à tour trois ici peut-être mais
tours 3 du coup il y aura non pas ça
fait quoi bah du coup tours troyes
s'était jamais possible hélas est passée
presque avantage pour les blancs que je
dirais mais qu' il ya la tour qui veut
venir en bessin donc ça allait avoir ça
a l'air pas mal
là peut-être aux cavaliers là pour
revenir
ces 5 c'est ce que leur dit proposer
mais je sais pas ça me paraissait un peu
bizarre du coup c'est quand même mieux
sa cave cay et c'est cet après midi huit
web est là bas personne que ce cas et si
c'est ça me paraissait bien après 3,8
par contre faut défendre ce pur de 6
j'aimerais bien passer la tour f 5 mais
du coup il y aura toujours en d6 ouais
donc là il veut changer les cavaliers
ses salaires archi nul ça calme ces
trois voix c'est ce qu'elle a fait
elle a fait cette fois du coup c'est
pour ça qu'il fallait gardes tu avais
vraiment garder les cliques alliés sur
l'échiquier moi moi je pense à la
caresser 7 ici sur wabush après fallait
faire des trucs comme ça je pense pour
défendre ce pion et après essayer de
passer la touriste et causer des
problèmes du poil à les changer toutes
les pièces et l'art c'est archi nul mais
je pense que ça même vous même petit
avantage pour l'énorme salaire un peu
plus facile pour une offre surtout si
elle fait des offres
ouais non quoique c'est sympa avantages
du tout ouais c'est juste hors chine
ouais donc ça c'était assez prévisible
et y reste 10 18 secondes donc ça veut
dire que ces raisons à ces temples de
recommencer la partie de recommencer une
autre partie ça veut dire que ça sera
pas la pause ouais
du coup elles ont repris elles ont
réussi à battre le temps et le temps
s'est écoulé à elle a vécu de 1505 boul
ouais donc là clairement l'idée est que
ça pue la priorité pour elle mais bon il
a quand même gardé un petit niveau parce
qu'il joue pas une partie monisme salut
fond
donc je trouve ça même à chaque fois
donc qu'il rappelle pour ceux qui
viennent de nous rejoindre ça c'est les
à paris
donc la salle est gagnante du prochain
du précédent match des précédents
matches avec l'agglo il y avait mis
bissara et maintenant on va voir qui
c'est qui va pouvoir se qualifier aussi
ou à la prochaine ronde
donc ça se passe est intéressant de voir
ça donc voilà on repasse est donc cette
ligne avec cavalli et à eux deux ces
faits c'est ce que joue donc c'est un
peu ma ligne politique est elle le joue
à chaque fois donc là trois parties de
suite elle a besoin
donc on s'est bien préparé la tuer la
première partie son adversaire vais
jouer pareil et la deuxième partie elle
avait changé on peut donc y s'il avait
joué cavalier m6 est donc là cette fois
les oies et des revenus à sa première
ligne donc là je pense que ça sera
clairement bien pour continuer parce
qu'elle sera dans le genre de police ont
qu à lannion
la ouais mais bon c'est quand même des
gros sacrifices juste pour être forte
hausse de chaque bon aussi je suis faut
absolument rien faire dans la vie je
serai juste pour bien jouer la favorite
s'est pris fin
donc là d'un projet de salle à rien
noufou n'est pas prenable parce qu'il y
aura match est ok donc la même ça sent
bon ok donc d'abord l'a voulu chasser le
roi mais c'est pas forcément une très
bonne chose parce que je trouvais que le
foot est bien placé pour taper sur le
kavé saisisse d'un faut prendre les 5
plus depuis en france a l'air bien aux
têtes nantes dans certains cas il y
aurait même des dames au projet si suivi
de détourage 3 memorial fund ça c'est
pas possible mais ça serait ça serait
drôle peut être que ça puisse marcher
du coup là je pense juste prendre donc
ça sera la salle frémit
donc là le pion à attaquer donc bien sûr
ceux fournis le débat n'est pas prenable
ce pays aura toujours des menaces pas
d'être vraie recette pour défendre
surtout rêve 7 atteint 9,7
ça me paraissait un peu bizarre que si
la dame une télé fait d'être peut-être
avoir de sacrées poil mais pour le
moment ça a l'air de tenir
je pense qu'il faut défendre le foufou
faire des détours effarante être précède
défendre et après après peut-être qu'on
pourra concert des découvertes mais pas
pour longtemps puisque bien sûr ça s'est
fait attaquer
l abattre car le salon alexandra est là
bas ce qui d'autre à part lui
lahmadi kevin il est plus fort que grâce
à mon époque on veut dire c'est vrai que
sa revue
c'est un gros succès alors là il ya
peut-être des découvertes il peut
marcher
faut voir cette foule ou boulanger 3 ou
alors fois chier c'est peut-être même
foot g5 pour voir ce qui se passe
peut-être même faux j'ai cinq civils à
hk trou alors fou g3 ce village théâtre
un peu ça peut ça peut avoir des des
grosses menaces
voilà je pense qu'il parle sur
l'échiquier
j'imagine basque sur internet tout le
monde peut pas tout le monde savait pas
dire on joue à moins que ça soit enfin
officiel comme dans ce genre de
compétition mais oui sinon ça ne veut
pas dire grand chose
voilà donc là on aimerait bien prendre
bien sûr il ya souffrance et 4
tel faut juste mettre le fou morlaàs et
après faire de type nas ou alors même
mettre le foulard et 7 et 7 prendre
j'espère pour pas qu'ils soient attaqués
si tu m'envoies en rien la cheville
malheureusement c'est là je regarde
juste sur le sur le portable pages
publiées sur portable du coup mais vous
pouvez pas voir moi du coup je te faire
ça quand même
mais du coup vous verrez pas vous verrez
juste que je me marrais sur une sur une
vidéo
en 2009 fois c'était librement mais du
coup je fais 1 face à elle mais du coup
je vois jouve apparaît le moment où
élèves ou est là je construis
et donc après cette partie d'ailleurs ça
serait la dernière avant la pause et
juste pour le petit rappel ça c'est le
format de jeu donc il ya en fait il ya
ya ça c'est l'élève et sa joueuse huit
invités et
bah je crois que le son s'est coupé
d'ailleurs je me suis pas rendu compte
que vu que y avait plus de sens quand je
suis allé là bas donc ok bon du coup là
on échange de tours ça serait pas
forcément la faveur des blancs quoique
peut-être en train de changer au tour et
après faire des foulées 3.7 tapé mon âge
c'est peut-être possible
enfin si tu veux pas c'est bien mais en
fait je regarde mon lit le chat sur mon
portable je regarde pas sur l'ordi donc
c'est pour ça que vous verrez parce que
c'est ce que je fais je veux pas juste
les glissant lien et vous montrez fait
c'est ça c'est ça ce que je voulais dire
mais sinon le lien c'est un peu on peut
poster bien sûr aux missions spéciales
way du coup là j'ai regardé en fait la
vidéo qui m'a envoyé mais enfin j'ai
regardé ans
très rapidement je vais juste enfin je
suis allé à choyer c'est assez
rapidement et j'ai pas vu vraiment vu le
moment où elle avait joué contre lui est
ce que c'est marqué la partie aurait
seront voilà partis en direct parce que
là je voyais qu'elle le couilles avec
1,5 et jouer contre 1 en gros c'est que
je me suis trompé
chatroom le gaza ça serait moins cher
non si elles seront plus qu'un seul bon
du coup non non c'est pas l acea à royan
contrat libre j'oublie ce que je vois je
peux ça un peu plus tôt alors voilà je
vois seulement et arroyo compte rien de
choquant vote
enfin je vois aussi qu'ils ont joué
ensemble mais je vois pas la partie et
je vois pas le sport
alexandre oui voila j'ai vu j'ai vu bien
sûr j'ai vu qu'ils vont jouer ensemble
mais je voulais voir la partie en fait
je voulais voir le résultat de leur
parti ouais as-tu m'envoyait hockey que
ces mecs beach hockey nous être ça c'est
la bonne vidéo qu'est haye était
toujours à l'époque
ouais donc elle commente ok donc les
tout à la fin mais maintenant la battue
voilà donc si la dalle à la fin ça l'est
vraiment mignon tour tourbe et de ses
seins mortal kombat c'est quoi ce quoi
ce pays envahi par peindre je dis ça
chez vous ça c'est sûr
[Rires]
mais bon on lui dit pas mot
ouh là du coup elle va gagner elle va
gagner je pense parce que ce qui avait
été totalement fermé et il paie pas
vraiment sortir bien sûr parce qu'à
chaque fois il faut qu'il défend le pion
contre le pion h7
beaucoup de ce qu'elle a tout ce qui lui
reste à faire c'est d'essayer d'aller
prendre ce qu'ils ont et après
éventuellement n'est pas gagné vu que
jamais quoi que ce soit c'est simple
parce que maintenant c'est le roi qui
peut être dépendant sa non non c'est non
mais non ça fout b2 et hachette qui
bouge la pièce sans la jouer
ce qui m'étonne c'est qu'il n'est pas
balancer l'effet les pièces après la
partie du coup il a gagné donc là le
score ça incroyable 125 et demi à deux
ans et demi on sait déjà qui va gagner
je pense pas c'est plus trop de plus
trop de suspens
du coup la vue qu'on mon avis là c'est
le times time is a donc la pause face à
l'heure de la pause et ça sera l'heure
de faire du 3 + 2 nokla les parties vont
reprendre bientôt
je pense qu'il y aura une petite pause
de cinq minutes comme comme d'hab
bon bah du coup en attendant je vais
faire ma petite pause aussi je serai de
retour
[Musique]
donc ça a repris à of may vous voyez pas
le nouvel échiquier bizarre
mais c'est bizarre il ya un vague à l'az
là c'est le grand 17e et la femme sait
que le temps millau ils changent pas
bizarre ce qui se passe
lens
ah c'est bon ça a repris ok ok c'est bon
là le tente on est ok alors bon cette
position je dirais qu'elle est déjà un
gros avantage pour les membres basque
sur kelly prend il y aura il y aura tout
reprendre fodé cissé il ya toujours des
on imagine donc ça a l'air déjà super
super compliqué et même sur sam à venir
peut-être juste fou prend ouais donc la
prairie que le fou donc apparemment elle
se disait que c'est mon action c'était
pas si t'as pas pas très correct
donc ouais bah oui elles venaient à
défaillir mettre la pression sur le fou
peut-être que dans certains cas elle
peut aussi pousser là mon avis il ya un
mais deux parce que ça se ramasse d'un
bep 2 oui bon ça aussi ça marche pas ça
paraît et du coup ce rouage suroît g8 y
aura quand même d'un 2002 je vous prends
et après avoir amélioré motte way sur
cent il ya un tour en 1 8
annonc n 1 billion elle a bien marché la
donc elle sait bien s est bien battu on
est revenu on peut dans le match grâce à
toi
moi vas-y tu peux poster un lien
mais bon je te prends
qu'a donc là tu m'as donné depuis le
lien d'animaux a allégué du hockey elle
a enfin l'intention à l'honneur ce a
abandonné le fait du hac de gagner
c'était pas vraiment surprenant en effet
sont au canada une dame depuis le depuis
longtemps
ou pas
et comment certains ont un peu froid
je me suis transformée en docteur
à l à fait calme en livres seulement sur
ses parties ce beat c'est faux ça assez
en dvd et là vraiment bien géré ça ça
pue d'ailleurs payé tout ça ces dvd six
livres et tout ça l'a vraiment trop bien
verrai si j'ai même entendu dire qu'elle
qu'elle a vu qu'il avait une collection
d'habits pour bébé ou je sais pas quoi
je sais tout ça grâce à son pinceau
titre de pièces queen
du coup la main c'est une bonne business
business woman manukula je vois pas je
vois pas qui l'a battu assez marqué sa
marque et la bastille ou carlson l'a
battu à nantes elle n'a pas tout gâcher
ma faim rognant morose irish coffee
shops pour garder dijon ça fait beaucoup
ça fait beaucoup en effet surtout qu'à
l'époque il était quand même super fort
sur le ragga chinoise malheureusement je
crois qu'il n'existe plus
malheureusement mais alors des restes
web c'était aussi fort aussi nâdiya
l'époque et il était super fort du coup
c'est une sur un beau et bon bon bon bon
mix m'a d'ailleurs j'ai déjà battu andy
tant est que c'est du cul
j'ai déjà battu c'était à monaco
un bail ici à ici pendant la journée il
fait il fait super beau
d'ailleurs il fait un grand soleil et on
met là en soirée là il avait déjà dit
leccia 19h50
ici commence à faire un peu en peu froid
du coup c'est un peu trompeur la météo
ouais c'est 5 c'est bien ouais mais
ljuboja f5 ou la m5
mais elle n'a pas lu la paille ou à moi
j'aime bien les bits soit plus deux
comme ça je peux faire tomber je me
devais refaire ça me fait plaisir
bon du coup on aimerait bien faire d un
des deux cartes peut-être du coup
peut-être fou des deux enfin moi je
dirais moi j'aime bien faire des gaffes
riches et pas si c'est correct mais moi
j'aimerais bien
donc ça juste pour rappeler ça c'est les
appariements donc voilà fait là on en
est à la cause c'est mieux contre
grenoble i donc saleh à 23 et là pendant
quatre 4 jours de suite je crois il y
aura il y aura des partis tous les jours
donc ça sera assez intéressant ça passe
ça se passerait assez vite du coup parce
que ouais on va en fait on va finir
toutes les parties là qu'on voit on va
finir stefanova quand tout corrie quoi
je condamne inns & lighting j contre
shalit toutes et tous ces partis là wide
fini avant dimanche
donc la première phase se terminera
dimanche donc ça se fasse et ça sera
assez cool parce que du coup samedi au
mas de roux en fait il y aura une ronde
un peu plus tôt une autre ombre au plus
tard voilà donc donc ça sera assez cool
de regarder ça et après ça sera déjà les
matchs des gagnantes gagnantes ouais ça
serait l'image des gagnants plutôt que
là c'est juste les matchs choix entre
les invités et les qualités c'est comme
ça qu'ils ont fait ça
du coup ils ont quand même beaucoup trop
mais on peut pas le voir malheureusement
ce n'était pas dans mon billet ça marche
ça détectés par cas qu'elle a c'est bon
j'ai quand même des gros soucis avec mon
fils est sain que le temps ils bougent
pas c'est bizarre ça que du coup vous ne
vous me dîtes si jamais un efi qui ils
veulent et qui marche plus c'est un peu
bizarre ça qu'il ya autant de autant de
problèmes les cadences alors ça je ne
sais pas je pense que ça changera quand
même ou alors peut-être pas non je pense
que ça sera ça sera la même entre entre
les masses là que l'on fait les hommes
mais qualificatif on veut dire et et des
uns et les autres à c'est pareil c'est
le city bag
j'ai bouclé bieber bois c'est bizarre
d'habitude j'ai tellement début d'une
habitude comment oublier celle des
problèmes que que je pense même pas que
ce soit la faute peut-être de de quelque
chose qui n'est pas sous mon contrôle
donc j'ai l'impression que c'est
toujours ma food aid est la faute de mon
ordi web tels que cette chose doit comme
du goût bon là ça là ça a l'air d'être
assez assez nul je pense que bon ils
vont essayer de faire des trucs comme ça
moi je passerai ans on suit
personnellement et j'essaie de faire
j'essaie de faire vous aussi ce je pense
qu'il devrait peut-être tenté ça mais
bon on n'a pas essayé
peut-être que le problème c'est qu'il y
avait foule faisait trois lois y avait
peut-être pousser soi
ça va il affiche cinq enfants elle m'a
dit donc c'est un peu ce que je suis en
train de faire là je commence à être un
pion est ce que les effets partie du
staff c'est faire partie du staff de
chess doigt comme par alexandra
donc là il reste trente minutes pour les
beats 3 + 2 donc on dirait que là ils
ont ils ont réduit un peu la cadence du
que non enfin vu claque il aurait dû le
timer mais que la cadence un peu plus
rapide y z'ont pas besoin de faire
autant d' autant de folie
ils vont faire autant de partis mais ils
ont ils ont pas besoin de le faire
autant de temps que ça soit un peu en
poésie
non moi j'ai pas eue sur moi je ne fais
pas partie du staff là c'est seulement
je pense que je pense qu'elle bosse
fourchette doigts comme ça pour ça moi
je fais juste des scream monsieur je le
boss pas vraiment pour eux elle je pense
qu'elle doit s'occuper de trucs spéciaux
ok du coup là savent assez lentement et
réfléchi tout les deux assez longtemps
donc la d3 beaucoup si le 4 ça a l'air
pas mal
peut-être aussi à des trucs ouais carte
je pense que je pense que c'est c'est
vraiment naze acer j'allais dire gdh 3
et g4 mais bon ça c'est vraiment trop
mais moi c'est ce que je ferai en phase
sur ce trajet 4 même si ça ne voyait
donc elle a fait ça ok donc ça c'est
normal pris ce prix est le sens
[Musique]
ouais ça l'air de pas vrai problème en
est rien pour chaises comme rue ouais
donc ça c'est assez normal oui mais
messi est là le pion ça veut dire
qu'elle ait essayé beaucoup plus que ce
que streams
ça veut dire que je pense qu'elle doit
elle doit avoir accès à des trucs
particulier non ce n'est pas comme si
elle se trouve elle elle fait de la
modération pour pour la triste ou alors
pour quelque chose de l'autre
ou alors elle fait vraiment des trucs
pour améliorer celle d'un homme parce
que sinon elle aurait par exemple la
plupart des streamer ils n'ont pas le qi
enfin bon moi je suis moi je suis aussi
streams et j'aurais appuyons mon coeur
mais à mais je les vois passer si
c'était juste
c'était juste des streams on met du coup
ça l'est pas moi je ferais bien des h3g
4 ça me tente bien ça j'ai passé ces six
est cool ou pas mais voilà moi je
préviens ça
ou alors même acheteur peut être et sur
gk de faire faire des cas légers 5 mai
les noms qu'elle g5r h 10 du coup h 15
j'ai quatre faut mettre le kavé lyon ont
des cartes peut-être ça fait ça devait
pas arriver clairement pas arrivé mais
surtout pour en acheter tu aurais damas
schiste du coup ça s'appelle ça peut
être pas mal mais peut-être survie
rentrer comme ça la prochaine pas d'hier
que tu veux si je vais leur poser un
ultimatum vrai ça serait drôle alors la
callas cas ça m'a pas l'air hyper sa
main ce qu'on fait
by ap th 4 ou 2 et 3
ou alors ouais je sais pas moi
j'aimerais bien des tours j ai peut-être
pas toi tu jouerais g3 floquet ouais bon
aussi
ouais peut-être h k way
oui
là c'est bon
mof mort du coup du ca vraiment tout cas
c'est alors c'est vrai c'est vraiment
tout cas c'est l'évasion mais j'étais en
train bien imprudent j'en remercie pour
l'alerter tout est en train de dire
qu'un plein de trucs mais du coup mais
au moins ça dort ou là du coup ça ça se
rapproche au niveau 1 niveau score 6 à 5
5 ans à être ouais ouais plus de cent
plus de caméras plus rien mais du coup
là je voulais donner en chair et os en
fait mais du coup ça n'a pas trop marché
vu que je suis pas modérateur j'essaie
de le faire avec mon propre avec ma
propre chaîne rai vu que je suis pas
mode saas à passa pas changé au sein pas
marché
bon du coup peut-être des fouets ce cas
précis suivi deux tours des ans et après
et cette poussée c'est ça ou alors même
sens que ça pourrait être pas mal
ou alors faire des coups normaux comme
kung fu et trois essais de faire des
tours tour c'est un tour d on essaie de
causer de problèmes même même
ouais comme j'ai dit un peu plus tôt
pousser les sciences à l'air pas mal
donc d'alger 4 aussi c'est intéressant
plate pour faire [ __ ] g5
ouais mais du coup après c'est ce
qu'avait dit obligé de repartir
ouais du coup il est obligé de repartir
et ça a pas l'air top monde uk abc 3 il
y aura peut-être des kabyles dessin
suivi de kayes et c5
ouais voilà merci pour les charentes a
voté manuel boy
ouais je pense que le bullet vois ça
sera un 6 1 ça sera fou de voir ce qui
va se passer
d'ailleurs si le bullet c'est vraiment
compté comme vu que c'est compté comme
comme les parties beats c'est vraiment
quand même en fait qui compte le bullet
chance je pensais qu'en fait il aurait
un coût et visions 10 ans pourrait que
le bullet que ça vaudrait un peu moins
que le coût des parties bis mais c'est
pareil enfin ça c'était pareil du coup
pas parce que les buts c'est pas des
vrais échecs donc c'est un peu bizarre
qu'ils fassent ça mais du coup ça marche
bien quand même
vous avez pas d'en louper grand chose je
vais vous inquiétez pas du coup là
j'imagine il va essayer de faire des
gestes mais du coup c'est assez
dangereux parce que ça donne la cazelle
5 fera peut-être des cavaliers de en
plus pour aller au f5 avec elle et
décale km5 ça a l'air super forts
salaires hyper fort je pense que j'ai 5
c'était une grosse gaffe
ouais ça m'a vraiment ouais mais fallait
qu'elle fallait qu'elle empêche f4 du
coup voilà du coup ça doit passer le
même mais bon je pense que j'ai cinq ans
même où il faut vraiment éviter
alors non je n'ai pas vraiment de
préférence pour pour les joueuses n'ont
pas pas vrai ouais non j'ai déjà pas
vraiment référence vraiment pas en fait
c'est juste qu'il ya que la meilleure
gagne c'est tout ici là je pense vu que
je connais un peu plus quoi signaux que
j ai raté continue mais mais bonjour mon
ça me changera pas ma vie qu'elle gagne
meslier entre le match de qualité avec
mon goût mais nina là j'étais un peu tôt
pour kaka parce que je me disais que
enfin et jouer quand même bien et la
plupart des gens vous étiez pour
pourrait donc donc j'étais plus tôt pout
tout pour elle mais ouais mais du coup
là sur ce match et je suis en veut un
peu en personne
donc du coup voilà ça être un peu ça va
être un peu faux parce que du coup
l'option quartier y tombe il va tomber
du coup elle est là c'est défendre le
film death est ce parce que sur sur dame
d'un point qu'a qui avait faut prendre
des 6 ou un an plus tôt attendant
certains me caty y avait tout tour 3
filles année la date où elle c'est un
peu embêtant en effet c'était un peu g
du coup vous êtes pour qui ou en fait de
tous les joueurs vous êtes papier
oui ce que vous voyez est entre tous ces
joueuses là vous êtes pour rien en fait
disons moi je pense que oui fans va
gagner parce que c'est clairement la
plus forte mais il ya aussi d'amédée vu
que là je lui en géorgie je pense que
dès que je serai pour elles mêmes et non
peut-être j'ai pas en fait j'ai vraiment
pas favorite parce que je les connais
toute assez bien aussi ana maudit choqué
au sia est aussi assez assez sympa
surtout de super sympa où nina aussi est
sympa ouais sont tous à padoue du coup
je suis vraiment pas aux personnes
du coup à duke ou alors là bon 13
secondes ça va être un peu compliqué et
ça a toujours pas bougé depuis c'est fou
hein si ça bouge et ça a bougé mais ça
ça fait ça ça change j'avais passé mon
écran non mais si oui les femmes c'est
clairement la numéro un mais la deuxième
c'est judith mon gars elle est corrélée
à froid dans la première c'est jeudi
pôle gare la deuxième c'est oui femme
met en jeu des bols pas garages ou
claude hêche avec cette personne
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a combat mais pour
les fans c'est clairement la numéro un
mondiale va maintenant par un parmi
design les actifs donc je pense qu'elle
va quand même gagné je pense qu'elle va
gagner mais bon vu que c'est du bluff on
ne sait pas trop est ce que pensait
d'ailleurs quel est son aile au blitz
homme ou une femme
un voyage qui était numéro 2 baning
presque 2600 c'est faux
combien de points rouges possèdent j'en
possède deux mille cent soixante dix ans
truc de leur dit-on encore harricana 6 à
6 partout c'est fou ça
6 partout ça va c'est vraiment une belle
remontée de la part de la rigueur
ouais ouais du coup je pensais que ça
serait compris en fait que ça serait
arik air qui est le plus de problème est
en fait du coup assez caustique qui est
en bilan bullet à être grandpierre pour
aller au bout la bulle est là il va
arriver dans l'eau il va arriver bientôt
il va arriver bientôt donc à lacets de
la pause annoncée pas la cause il
continue mais du coup dans dans seize
minutes sans pascal bullet
ouais ouais mais bon ça c'est juste le
lait l'eau à jeddah comme ça veut pas
dire grand chose ça juste les los ché ce
point comme on l ofid je pense que son
blitz est beaucoup moins élevé que ça
elle est quand même fort bien sûr mais
c'est pas c'est pas ce niveau là parce
que 2007 ans et justin c'est juste un
coupable
donc là peut-être faire des trois
j'imagine pour protéger ce point
complète des cartes en fait ça peut être
pas mais décalent d'un certain qu'un je
pense pas que le client sera sera faible
donc ça devrait aller ouais des quatre
ça ça doit être pas mal
j'avais juste en faveur de tours c8 ou
de fous cavaliers à 5 mais ça a l'air de
ne pas être ne pas poser de gros soucis
mais bon ces diagonales qui s'ouvre ça
pourrait poser des problèmes en blanc
surtout s'ils perdent leur fou leur foi
important en 2000 en 1513 ap un but ô
combien infidèle
alors ça dépend ça dépend de s'il a
l'habitude de jouer des parties longues
aussi ou alors s'ils jouent juste des
beats parce que s'ils jouent juste des
bits alors en partie longue il aura pas
l'habitude il jouera très mal il
essaiera de glisse et de faire des
petites d'arnaqué à istres trop re
superman répondre donc ouais c'est pas
du tout aigri équivalent justement
savait vraiment rien dire ça dépend
aussi de ce qu'il avait l'habitude de
jouer comme dit ça peu disons en vieux
grand maître aussi qui a qui a
l'habitude de jouer depuis très
longtemps mais qui est très lent et qui
a peut-être pas l'habitude de jouer en
fait de jouer en ligne c'est qu'il est
nul aussi en informatique c'est qu'il
aurait dû 1200 alors que sombre et l
ofida soit 2500 parce qu'il a en partie
longue c'est beaucoup plus facile de
mettre en deux fins de montrer le loonie
enfin tout toute la connaissance que
quelqu'un peut avoir
donc disons il peut connaître les
finales super bien ou alors il peut
connaître la stratégie est vraiment
super bien mais en bits ça ce n'est pas
vraiment ça c'est vraiment juste de la
rapidité la tactique donc ça dépend
aussi des points forts de chacun voilà
c'est non 8 fini
explications tout ça pour dire que ça ne
veut rien dire donc là les placer ses
pions lamolère assez menaçants tant
qu'il y aura des d'abord faut que la
dame et bout parce que sinon bah les
cubains pourront par avance est telle
que la dame elle devrait bouger aussi
j'aime pas le fait qu'elle regarde la
tour on aimerait bien aussi bouger le
fou et lui apporter de faire des fous
c'est simple mais bon y'a de kabeya donc
c'est ma mission
oui c'est vrai ça aurait en effet dans
la paix
ouais il ya beaucoup moins de stress
pendant les parties en ligne bien sûr je
vois pas qui c'est qui pour être précis
alors qu'il joue juste deux parties le
bain juste pour le fun alors que alors
qu'en vrai c'est bon signe
alors oui c'est bon ce programme si du
site du progrès sur internet tant que tu
le fasses d'une bonne façon si tu
progresses en bullet ça veut rien dire
si tu progresses en partie rapide alors
oui c'est un très bon signe parce que
les parties rapides c'est quand même
assez similaire ou aux partisans du crs
c'est pas tout le monde savait ouais
ouais je connais des gens qui pètent des
câbles à chaque fois qu'ils perdent les
parties elles mêmes
ça je pense que c'est plutôt bon en
dessous six hommes en soucis personnels
ouais ouais je connais je vais je
connais des gens qui pètent des câbles
incroyable il parle plus à personne
quand il fait en départir en ligne alors
qu alors que c'est juste pour le fun
ouais ouais et aussi on peut juste on
peut faire des sacrifices on peut tenter
un peu plus en ligne que dans les vrais
partis donc non couiza et savait pas
dire grand chose cet espace est aussi ça
libère la pression comme tu as dis donc
on peut on peut beaucoup plus tentés
c'est vrai on peut faire des ouvertures
ou n'importe comment avec comme on l'a
comme la drogue ou alors je vous vois là
bas le bangla odom tout çà ou là du coup
là le pew il est perdu donc surtout re
1,1 à tour ans il y avait toujours des
3c salle pas ici sur tourer il y avait
il y avait toujours des 3 ouais donc ça
marche pas trop
ouais ouais tu me fous la ncaa et va
perdre enfin re a priori on va perdre
parce que du coup il y aura des tours d2
qui vont arriver ça a l'air assez assez
d'émissions toxiques ayache 4 avec à
liège 4 salers à leur bord
ouais
maintenant donc que c'est nul on va
prendre la vence donc c'est pas très
surpris parce qu'elle est là quand même
beaucoup mieux qu'elle mais bon c'est
vrai que larry qu'elle était vraiment
revenu n'ont ni match à cadence un peu
plus courte
donc elles ont repris il reste en plus
moins de dix minutes et après ça sera du
bullet cela j'ai vraiment hâte de voir
le bullet ça va être n'importe quoi on
allait voir en vue des cinq régates dans
les matchs précédents en bullet c'est
assez drôle hein moi je joue depuis que
j'ai 5 ans et demi j'en ai 22 donc ça
fait un petit moment de faire des f4
temps des fous de aussi pour empêcher
qu'elle g4 mais bon ça l'empêchent part
d'un monsieur ouais ouais de lukula le
cavaly il est carrément partie
et du coup beaucoup jeu mais le jeu mais
juste les les appariements le match
le match de demain ça sera ça sera entre
stefanova et cory donc ça sera demain on
a à peu près la même heure à chaque fois
donc voilà c'est sale et ça sera comme
moi qui monte et ça c'est je le ferai
jusqu'à jusqu'à dimanche mais les
commentaires c'est déjà ces jo ou aux a
planifié du coup voilà repassons à la
partie g45 croyable c'est ce qu'elle a
fait g4 ben dis donc t'es là un peu par
hasard tu voulais aller sans et six
femmes a dit donc tu vois là derrière
des parents fait et j'espère que je sors
c'était c'était aussi divertissant que
notre mix du coup
bon j'aurais pu essayer de me qualifier
mais j'ai pas j'ai pas essayé du coup je
me j'ai pas fait au camp dit on en fait
j'ai fait au cours de trois
et voilà parce que je pensais que
j'avais aucune aucune chance de me
qualifier
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas essayé de
gagner du middle west du de 20000 volts
en vingt huit balles voilà du coup du
coup peut-être que c'est un bon
l'intéressé mais bon ok bien sûr j'ai
aucune chance de rêve de gagner bien sûr
elles sont ils sont quand même un an ça
crie ça crie niveau comparable
mais bon ça reste à lui été marrant j'ai
déjà battu quelques dunes d'ailleurs de
deux joueuses
j'avais battu troyes musicaux que les
bains tuer comme disait aussi battu
continuer mais bon quand même des pâtres
une fois savait pas dire que je que je
vais y avoir un bon score que l'on fait
alors non je n'ai pas pour a prévenu en
fait vu que là le cheval france il a été
annulé
je vais juste faire le top dos féminin
je pense ça se passe juste quelques
parties ce sera juste juste pour
s'amuser un peu
enfin c'est pas vraiment pour s'amuser
mais ces ambiances fo ne s'est pas
vraiment gros tournoi c'est pas le genre
le cheveu à 35 heures c'est juste voilà
c'est ça sera juste pour pourvoir les
potes de mon équipe et tout ça et aussi
pour espérer gagner bien sûr pour pour
gagner enfin avec mulhouse je joue donc
si on arrive à se qualifier pour la
coupe d'europe ça sera cool mais même si
c'est surtout j'espère juste pour
pourvoir les voûtes demande
bon il ya quand même une sacrée ambiance
entre 2006 et en 2008 sans vraiment
c'est vrai que nous nous en tant que co
pauvres joueurs on le voit pas trop mais
ouais mais à sa fin alors dit il au
brooklyn et ça se remarque
j'aime beaucoup c'est vrai ça c'est vrai
c'est vrai en effet il ya beaucoup de
très bons entraîneurs comme par exemple
de redskins ou alors ou alors deux
adjoints qui avait une sacrée
compréhension du jeu mais bon lors leur
niveau ils chilien n'était pas n'était
pas top
bon du coup il reste plus que cinq
minutes cinq minutes sont donc là je
pense que bien sûr le pont chrétien fini
sa partie nous pouvons encore en refaire
une autre
et après ça sera l'heure du bilan j'ai
vraiment hâte que ça soit des bullet ça
va être vraiment drôle c'est parti là
bon là d'un point 4 salaire de
simplement gagner pour harry ko l'a pas
fait
non c'est faux elle pouvoir l'a pas fait
d'emprunt 4 hélas hélas pas lu je pense
mais ce fou sont d'un point qu'un seul
verre de gagner tout simplement
mais bon la taxe à pioncer 2 mais du
coup là il ya calvet ya quand même
qu'ils dépendent calais ces trois ou six
à l'heure de départ mais il ya cahiers
pour 1,4 nous
oui oui je vois ce qui l'est moins c'est
pourquoi j'ai dit à jeudi à il était dit
il était là mais youku et c'était une
légende mais aussi au yukon le croire
mais où il s'était aussi un très très
bon entraîneur ouais ouais c'est sera je
crois que ça sera 45 minutes de belote
ou tête 20 minutes il faudra voir ce qui
est ce qui se fait à écrire après le
times
ouais ouais ouais ouais ça c'était ça
c'est vraiment les enfers de légende
dorée de ski yusupov 45 c'est un peu
trop ouais j'aime à lienz aut 2e minute
parce que je vais 45 du budget
ouais les pauvres
schürmann qui essaie sur man en fait je
le connais pas est-ce que c'était aussi
un banc l'entraîneur ou alors un
écrivain c'est qui
mais comment ont-ils vu les chais pas
comment je vais faire personnellement je
sais absolument pas je pense que ça va
être non surtout déjà là ça va tellement
vite
ouais là c'est quand même gros avantage
pour les noirs avec les deux plus en
plus ça fait quand même beaucoup
les bouquets yusupov surtout quand vous
commandez but hills échec c'est fait
c'est pas vraiment conseillé conseiller
oula ouais donc là la csn bay la capuche
pendant well as plus simplement on
pousser le cube peut être pousser les
pions ou alors d'abord faire wave 4
j'imagine et après et après pour le
pousser les pions ça d'ailleurs de
gagner mais du coup puisqu'elle a fait
ça ah oui non du coup de jets du coup ça
va quand même
ouais ça va quand même à y est presque
40 41 secondes
ok on célèbre entraîneur hockey
soviétique donc quelle pièce qu'il a
entraîné une bo de binic ce genre de
personne mois ou qui d'autre
ouais du coup là c'est très ses traits
symétriques tout ça ça s'appelle
asymétrique je crois mais mais non du
pour le coup c'est pas très symétriques
a opté que la symétrie cpt saïk des 5
ouais il faut c'est peut-être c'est être
papa effet c'est peut-être pas la même
diouf au f5 qu'avec des cartes non même
si une bonne réponse
voilà prise après hp en g3 salaire pas
de mal peut-être aussi les dames 17
ouais ouais quasiment wiki finir l'été
wikipedia pas xna
ouais donc ok donc michael bobigny une
bonne steinruck et hyman of watch my
baby doc qui a un sacré palmarès
bah dis donc le très vite donné ok ouais
c'est vrai c'est vrai je sais que c'est
moi je ne donne pas que n'a très jaloux
et il a écrit des livres ou pas
free but de serre pourquoi ce que 8 des
chefs facile a dit nous a sortis en
pavés c'est pour ça
et
ah il est tout aussi entraîneur de
karpov bah dis donc t'as pas fini
d'opale et alors c'est la suite ben dis
donc il a été troisième temps auront
posé par faire peuvent pas mal pas mal
non c'est faux
attend d'eux fume entre chaque partie
commence à ça c'est pas un magicien
5 pertes de puma un mineur des stream
c'est vrai bizarre ça m'a plu
non mais c'est vrai je pense pas que
c'est moi qui fais ça non je pense que
ça doit être au top et automatique par
tweet ou alors c'est automatique avec la
chaîne ne s'est pas bon en tout cas
c'est pas de ma faute je vous rassure
du coup j'ai fermé ma prof active du coi
pour rappel ça c'est ça c'est le saas et
les joueurs ça c'est quand même ça c'est
ma propre piège au cas où vous en avez
pas eu assez
merci le connaissait ah bah ça je ne
sais pas en fait
bon peut-être que je peux le faire sur
la sur la chaîne parce que c'est vrai
que j'ai des codes d'accès de la chaîne
mais du coup non en fait je fais je fais
juste le stream comme ça j'ai même pas
les commentaires directement sur le truc
donc
donc voilà je regarde mes poèmes et des
commentaires sur moi sur mon portable
donc je m'occupe pas trop de ce qui se
passe au train
ça va vous avez apprécié la pub alors
atteint dans l'histoire des jeux
d'échecs et d'espoir ouais ok c'est bien
donc tout va qui a gagné cette partie
dont wells était logique vu ce qui s'est
passé la finale était quand même bien
non attendons non ça c'est encore un nul
dont il s'est passé quoi ah parce que la
gaffe il a donné un pur elle a deux
elle a donné plus on aurait pensé qu'il
y avait ça et qui aurait eu que trois
mais du coup sûr de sûr tout reprend les
quatre est là juste deux notions
or la gare au no way c'est fou ça s'est
tellement moche au hockey ouais je mets
du coup je sais pas comment dans ses
débuts
moi même je sais pas comment le faire
est-ce qu'il ya jorand on commande mais
même la commande luxe et un modérateur
faudra que j'assure sur la normalité du
coup parce que sur un google apps word
je peux le faire mais du coup la fin que
j'ai essayé de 2,2 me connecter sur la
sueur sur le tweet en même temps ça fait
à tous tout bogey donc ouais donc je
vais éviter de de faire ça le problème
c'est que mon ordi est pas top
du coup quand j'essaie de de faire autre
chose sur mon ordi des fouaces aveugle
ou encore paris et vanille donc
[Musique]
le champion du monde du jeu avec les
bandits d'orge
ok mais il était si fort que ça parce
que là c'est quand même une sacrée
légende alors choisi s'ils étaient si
ses adversaires avaient tellement peur
de lui à 100 là bas du coup on dirait
qu'elle appose ah oui c'était la barre
partie du coup là ça sera leur double a
et désolé je connais pas mais non je le
connais et je me renseignerai sur le
hockey france prend bien soin d d des
fleurs et des choses au japon bon bah du
coup c'est la pause alors je vais faire
une petite pause je mettrai la pub comme
vous adorez mais c'est passé la cub de
chaises pour comme c'est pas c'est pas
sympa la pub de twitch aiba du coup
maintenant je connais au moins j'ai
connaît grâce à toi ok bah du coup je
vais faire une petite pause et je serai
de retour quand le bullet reprendra
voilà donc à tout de suite
[Musique]
sayah et viennent de reprendre
du coup je suis de retour au jeu je lui
fais ch
ok c'est bon là ok donc de temps comme
vous pouvez le voir le tendre de arica
c'est pas top
c'est vraiment pas top el hadj a perdu
deux minutes
bon par contre là le temps ni tour en
plus donc c'est un peu bizarre
le temps ne tourne plus bon j'espère que
cela sera réglé bientôt mais juste pour
vous dire arica maintenant on se
retrouve avec 17 secondes comptent
minutes
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment patent web
la move ait un mail et tenteront
toujours pas c'est fou ça
qu'est ce que le tendon au parlement ce
que j'ai l'impression à chaque fois
qu'un nouveau billet si le temps
s'arrête ah ok c'est bon c'est réglé ok
super ok alors bon à arica elle est mal
autant mais sa position elle est pas mal
est là la case de 4l à la casse est
froid aussi
elle a pas mal pas mal de 10 des
possibles mais bon là d'où cola il
changer la wii donc du coup à l'échangé
de la pièce du coup ça passait pas vous
fait elle n'avait pas trop le choix
france
e
bah du coup c'est l'équité été à homs et
deux nuls ok ça c'est le comble c'est
d'éviter jouant près terre alors le top
le top 5 de toujours préféré alors xna
rose ou alors le top 10 et je mets 10 et
un peu trop top 5
disons oui cic bull et avec 2 secondes
de plus soit at a répondu pas répondu à
temps j'ai pas vu à dans le désordre qui
est évoqué mais mais je vois pas en fait
si tu vas tu as juste dit t'as juste dit
c'est impossible à dire du coup tu
entendras pas seulement 10 on attend à
50 ou 60 ans ok ouais ouais ok ok non
mais je pensais que tu voulais pas
choisir voir le top 5 ou le tofu le top
ou le top trois meilleurs ouais ok ok ok
j'avoue j'avoue c'est une bonne réponse
c'est une bonne heure et anvers a le top
c'est qui alors j'ai pas vu c'est qui le
top 1 a le top 20 ans et furent indolore
du coup j'ai loupé ce message
ok bon ok oui le top ans je me doute
bien que c'est un peu difficile de
choisir
ouais ouais ok ok ouais temps il ya un
gros décalage quand même mais bon c'est
pas grave on arrive à ses enfants donc
vaut mieux tard que jamais donc là je
dirais que l'abolition des nord c'est
presque super bien joe riad et tout
reprendre cinq des fous des cartes qui
avait car il ya pas mal d'idées fischer
kasparov capable en k-league à l'heure
où bill shine starring c'est kitsch
tahri non je connais pas geller et stein
ouais ouais j'avoue bien dit non c'est
vraiment plus ça m'a pas une blague ça
va c'est ça la vérité ah non il peut pas
faire pour 291 c'était juste un tas
juste des problèmes si tu as envie de
faire ça ok masi jallet a tenté pavé
j'attends tes par viksna ou parce que du
coup je connais vraiment pas en fait je
connais absolument pas
[Rires]
attends maintenant bien recrues monsieur
nous j'aimerais bien ton nom plus quoi
ça servirait faux-pas faut pas lier faut
pas manger de tacos ça c'est sûr bon bah
si nul alors donc pour moi c'est
toujours pareil cas qui est un petit
avantage
bon du coup
ouais là là il ya des petits délinquants
mais a du coup là je pense que les noirs
ils vont essayer de pousser le 5 ça
c'est un c'est normal de faire détruire
jouets mais n'est-ce pas possible parce
que ça est vraiment trop défendu
peut-être ces 5
c'est simple possible merci pour le pour
le pour le nouveau pour le nouveau pavé
[Musique]
20 meilleurs joueurs du monde
ah ouais ok pas mal troisième du tour
lundi candidat hockey et pour est-ce que
tu l'amiante alors là je la comprends la
sémer qui pia qui dit beaucoup de bien
sur lui-même mais pourquoi toi est-ce
que tu l'on considère pas parmi les
meilleurs joueurs
qu'est ce qui le différencie des autres
s'il ya quand même beaucoup de joueurs
qui sont qui sont très forts ah ah oui
pas mal
ouais pendant trente ans ça fait
beaucoup
louette au vin pendant trente ans ça
fait beaucoup on a fait
bon du coup là les changes de tours ça
me fait pas du tout plaisir en fait cela
je pense qu'elle aurait plutôt dû faire
des trucs du genre autour des 6 j ma
jambe ou alors moi j'aurais bien aimé
faire des f4 mais mandoukou yaya toure
prends des anti qui fait que celle que
ça ne marche pas
j'ai pas trop trop niemand pour se
tourner en coop arias et joue ses
joueuses là j'ai pas trop trop le niveau
j'aimerais bien mais bon là je suis
assez bon du coup voilà c'est pour ça
que c'est pour ça que je ne joue pas
mais c'est vraiment bien qu'ils ne
devient jamais champion du monde
khadr est un ok alors score positif
contre bout de binic contre 6,9 péter
fischer
et puis tout ça c'est fou ça ah ouais
pas mal mais du coup c'est à ton avis
c'est quoi qui lui manquait alors pour
pour arriver en encore encore plus faim
pour avoir des meilleurs scores parce
que du coup pas les mêmes enfin je
connaissais même pas enfin j'avais déjà
vu sur le froid mais je pensais que
c'était juste un joueur parmi d'autres
il jouait trop pour le gamin ok ok ouais
donc oui il a accepté jamais là nul de
pouilly chercher des cherchait toujours
à pousser trop et après ouais y
perdaient en forçant donc c'est
l'inventeur de lestang diana aurait mais
pourrait vous pourrez lui rappeler les
stands des nanars mais pas la guerre
comme ça ils auraient ils auraient eu un
peu de crédit quand même
tu va encore nous sortir un autre
périphérique saint amand
là je pensais peut-être à db4 en fait ou
alors des c3 ne me paraissent pas moins
elle a fait p 4 elle a fait beaucoup
oui
ouais donc là c'est la femme avec la
colombie qui peut sourire enfin iliad et
peut-être des f4 aussi des dames à 5
aussi qu'il peut arriver ça peut être
pas mais
oh ok ok donc c'est pas lui qui a qui
l'a inventé c'est lui qui va juste
populaire est biaisé qui l'a popularisé
et qui l'a rendu web alors ok pas mal
ouais j'avoue j'ai sciboz mélissa c'est
vrai surtout bosnie qu'il est quand même
sens c'est quand même une des jambes
donc ouais il sait ce qu'il dit il était
avare de compliments ok ok donc quoi il
la méritait bien la whey j'imaginais fin
j'ai l'impression que c'était un mec est
vraiment très sévère a trait qui a et
qui faisait jamais elle sourit enfin
après enfin ça c'est l'impression que
j'ai de lui a bien sûr lui jamais vu
d'interview je pense que ça existait pas
trop à l'époque les interviews août est
qu'il y en a en fait et s'il ya des
interviews de de baudre unique parce que
je sais qu'un afficheur donc peut-être
qu'il y en a deux de nick du coup ça
m'intéresserait un fait mais du coup ça
serait un russe parce que j'imagine
qu'ils parlent et qui parlait pas oui
devait pas parler anglais
ouais ouais ouais
des gens qu'il faut polir les ont
trouvés l'inventeur wayne j'imagine
l'inventeur il devait il devait y être
il ya 400 ans
je vous laisse à pas la boire à foreman
geller et l'autre que je suis n'est pas
attendre pas tant je retrouvais ce que
tu m'as envoyé l'autre que je ne connais
pas ces stein stein je connais
absolument pas guerrero moi j'en avais
entendu parler des jamais stein
absolument pas
du coup le sport c'est toujours c'est
toujours pareil donc peut-être qu'elle
peut tenter des trucs genre h5 parce
qu'il faut vraiment qu'une d'entre elles
gagnent 6 à 6 et continua fois avoir le
même score ça ça ira pas en france je
pense que c'est l'heure de pousser poil
stein celle que dans une pierre
dix meilleurs joueurs mondiaux oh mais
c'est fou comment ça se fait que je les
connais pas alors du coup j'attends le
reste du pavé j'attends les infos là
champion ouais ok mais du coup quelques
pièces qu'il a battu jo reyes il a fait
des belles perfs et disent qu'il a gagné
des tournois des trucs comme ça
ok
ok c'est paul c'est comme ça annoncé en
axant vraiment en attaquant du coup il
me plairait bien vu que j'aime bien ce
style de jeu je pense que j'aurai je
vais regarder cette partie alors ques et
se fait chair des sas a fait ça c'est
pas un compliment qu'il en soit on s'en
fiche parents on s'en va a fait toute sa
vie ça ça c'est sûr un trio pierre
haigneré be gone away
ils avaient peur de me fischer là les
portes de style c'est fou ça ça j'aurais
pas cru par contre il avait carrément
peur de lui demander des renaudies
together steiner iphone
ok ça marche ça marche
faudra que j'aurais que je veux mettre
mes connaissances à new
mince alors bah du coup le un petit bug
pas se marquer à wil inquiéter attendons
deux pas de saint louis qui était rétif
eu réellement en mesure de l'inquiéter
boîte à raison par exemple
ouais seulement grâce aux parties de
galles erstein et fuhrmann noël lui sans
fin et l'eau serait à alpha 0 bientôt à
mon nom ce lancement ce moment aux
billets ça me dit du coup mon billet ça
peut du coup vous voyez pas ça au mode à
la jeu c'est de refaire ça c'est pas que
ça a marché
bon du coup ça non non ça n'a pas l'air
de marcher
du coup je vais essayer de faire ça que
lui d'une fin de mon autre
ah c'est bon c'est bon ça marche et là
c'est bon ok ok super bah désolé du coup
c'est mon hobby à ce salon bio ski avec
qui réunit blog
du coup la se disent partout j'étais
tellement focalisés sur guéret et ces
gens là que j'en ai oublié de dorian
vieux parti désolé désolé mais du coup
il ya vraiment un bug
le temps ne coupa faut que faut que je
fasse un truc pour changer ça bc 2
est-ce que c'est réglé c'est réglé ou
pas
on directement
on dirait que non en valeur
on le sait faire un truc là
ça bugue sévère genre tu parles des
chefs d' accord juste mon monstre hymne
à des problèmes parce que du coup là le
temps ils bougent pas
ouais c'est
le stream ouais ok ok ok à bonne soirée
monsieur nous depuis ses 12 ans donc il
a commencé tard alors il a commencé à 12
ans elle c'est à cette offre
wen manier soit pourquoi pas glissé pas
dans top 10 un pote c'est parce que tu
n'aime pas jouer parce que y aura dès
qu'ils sont mais qu'ils sont meilleurs a
les deux
ok ok ok ok les deux enquêtes d'accord
aussi ça veut que
du coup ça ça me rassure un peu mais je
pense que du coup c'est surtout mon obs
qui a des moyens
[Musique]
c'est surtout mon billet ce parce que du
coup oh mince alors ça ne
c'est bon c'est arrivé abbas est réglée
support
qu'il ait pas d'un livre ils vont ils
méritent pas le top 10 hockey ouais je
suis assez d'accord mais bon du coup je
connais pas trop les autres mais m'ayez
pas dans mon top 10 non plus je pense
mais bon mon top 10 est plutôt des
joueurs agressifs donc c'est pour ça
qu'il n'y a pas
car sinon tu te mets pas dans le top 10
bah dis donc un joueur qui n'a aucun
style choqué car ce n'est dans sa hotte
ben ouais moi moi moi personnellement ça
serait ça serait fischer talent
kasparov et après enfin des gens je leur
brune s'est jamais bien aussi amoureuse
et biches pas aussi j'aime j'aime bien
son style mes bras fait je connais pas
trop je connais pas trop les partis
c'est juste que à shirov aussi j'aime
bien aussi shirov j'aime bien
qui d'autre qui d'autre ben amor fille
mais bon morphil et si c'est pas
vraiment le même niveau que les autres
mais morphy j'aimais bien quand j'étais
petit
aouita louis malle dans ton top 10 il y
est ok c'est bien c'est bien donc
attentes tandis qu' alors dans tout te
dis c'est ce que tu as dit entièrement
les gens moi parce que du coup tu as dit
en temps je voulais voir tu as dit
fisher kasparov capablanca gahler a les
kin one can find my way donc savait pas
dit ça ça fait pas 10 du coup faut que
tu en dises faut que tu es en dit un peu
plus pourtant dix ans tandis plus
ouais de la qualité des parties ouais
bah il a manqué deux je crois mais duke
août a ajouté talbot dit non il ne
manque plus qu'un ah oui et victor rossi
victoire amène en tout temps à tous là
tout le temps a dit je crois je suis pas
parvenu il me semble peut-être que je me
trompe
un white appareils but a dit fisher
kasparov carole en cas ali king et leur
rubinstein sign et koch et du coup là tu
ajoutes ahoussi talent
du coup ouais silice howey beaucoup
ignoraient mais les nuls c'est
nécessaire c'est nécessaire français en
ce moment je pense que tous les tous les
joueurs du top du top mondial en ce
moment et unis fin ils font deux nuls
donc pas trop éviter ça
[Musique]
mind is ok donc tu la fermes à tulle ac
a même placé quelque part
du coup en tout cas ce que j'aime bien
c'est que je sais que maintenant on voit
les parties en direct
nine yeux se ferment la marche mais dans
thor ouais ouais c'est le dernier ouais
mais bon après je suis d'accord avec toi
parce qu'il ya quand même beaucoup plus
de les gens qui sont devant lui mais bon
il prend la place de murphy et kkr tous
voyons c'est la fin que le time's up
c'est la fin du coup la sale guerre
c'est la dernière partie est donc arica
est obligée de gagner
elle a pas le choix c'est les gagnants
si elle gagne du coup je pense qu'ils
vont continuer ils vont essayer de faire
un mort subite
mais oh ouais mais youku du coup elle
est obligée de gagner
je pense que ce à quoi ils font savoir
elle peut clairement essayé de pousser
pour le gain si elle fait d'un des deux
par exemple s'il essaie de prendre le
quand même ça aussi c'est bien ce
qu'elle a joué ses c'est de défaire des
trucs du genre ouais mais youku enfin
voilà elle n'a plus trop l'idée est
maintenant la prostitution c'est
dangereux aussi tour 6/4 et des cavs a
lieu cinq ça les rend peu dangereux du
coup
bon bah du coup ça sera la fin bientôt
ça arrive ça arrive
mince alors sans apport buggy s'est
encore grimentz
pour je fasse un truc là
bon bah du coup si si jeune à chaque
fois c'est si je refresh la paix je fais
la page ça marche pas mais du coup là ça
donne c'est pas cool ce qui se passe sur
tout moment final bon je peux vous faire
les commentaires sans vous voyez chiqué
mais du coup ça sera pas top
platine qui n'en prenaient pas
y avait encore une fois j'ai vu un
parité c'est fou ça
moi j'y peux rien moi j pat symonds rien
single désolé désolé des gens bon du
coup c'est la bonne position mais en
fait il lui reste huit secondes
ah bah vous voyez là ouais mais sauf que
le temps est oui
il tourne pas il coule pas le temps donc
mince alors
wes évidemment les plus belles marges
des eaux
ouais mais surtout que c'est les moments
critiques quoi c'est fou que ça marche
pas ce moment là
oh
bon bah ça vous avez vu un les bleus ont
gagné donc dronneau ben ali a gagné donc
ça va servir que le cema tient égale nom
qui aura les aura leu leu la partie mort
survie le mort subite assez fou ça c'est
fou qui se passe et c'est comme ça que
ça s'est passé j'étais quand même
largement gagnant sa nouvelle dame bien
joué un an camion je peux la pas mal
donc je reconnais pas donc tu peux
mettre encore un autre tabou sur les
festives
ça me dérange pas
wade et du coup ils vont faire encore
une autre partie et je pense que ça sera
bientôt à je pense qu'il y aura une
cause du coup ils vont reprendre bientôt
mais je sais pas quand ils vont
reprendre pas ça c'est ça le problème
du coup tant que juste voir s'ils ont
changé quelque chose
non ils ont toujours a pas une idée
score mais du coup beaucoup j'imagine
comme ça va commencer bientôt à l
velimir vie dont je connais pas non plus
pleinement que belloumi robic non je
connais pas
bon bah du coup ils ont déjà repris pas
ils ont déjà repris mais ça bug ou
encore afin ouais ils ont repris mais
s'aveuglent le temps ne coule pas
non
ah oui mais oui mais on met quoi non
mais je connais juste n'attaque jamais
passé c'est un joueur qui s'appelait
comme ça je connais la tacc velimir au
big one ça je connais je connais le nom
j'ai même pas ce que c'est ouais je
connais même pas ce que c'est en fait
schéma parce que cette pénurie qu'à mon
avis ça lui est toujours une possession
genre être 4g 4 à mon avis
ok bain de foule sur le web
ça paye ça bug a faim
celle non bonbons en ga en venir vite à
mâcher attend c'est une blague on attend
mais pourquoi velimir ilic
si la trouve sept à dix mains parfois de
tous les joueurs et qu'ils existent veut
pas que c'est juste des bonbons chacun
d'entre eux
où
nous
le
le mamba du coup
voilà c est ça marche
le temps coule ça marche à nous enfants
ok du coup on va quand même pouvoir
suivre la partie la partie finale ok ça
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle mais du coup
arica je pense que l europe disent aussi
des petits pieds mais bon tels que ça
c'est nul en fait x now qu'est ce que
t'en pense et ce que tu penses que c'est
nul c'est la police si j'en ri nord il
pousse je suis moi j'ai l'impression ils
peuvent peut-être poucet de détroit
prépa c'est le roi de 5 des quatre
essais 3 théâtre hip hop ou tenter ça
la partie a manqué son vol un âge d'or
ok ok donc c'est le hockey
ouais c'est aussi ce qui me semblait un
peu mais j'ai envie de pousser les trucs
genre détroit fazila je voulais faire un
brevet 5 en fait après poussée des trois
rois des 4es et 3es prendre le bus ou en
métro mais j'imagine c'est un enfant une
des blancs auront largement le temps de
devenir l'ordi x et costes et où là bas
pas vraiment inédit que c'était nul et
du coup elles ont pagnol du coup la ccl
match égal et y est encore amelia encore
le bug c'est fou j'en peux plus on est
regardé le temps a pas été toutes deux
de tourner c'est le fou ça
j'espère que c'est réglé non ça n'est
pas
t
salut marcelo donc à sa marge à nos
gosses ça marche c'est cool enfin ça
veut plus ok donc si l'ouverture est
l'un des plus tranchant de la théorie
des échecs hockey
ah oui ok c'est juste la sourdine ok
avec vous ces trois fous ces quatre
baies 3 après fou ou trois dames des
deux banques
ok pour le plonger auquel voiliers du
coût du kwh est je ne savais pas si
j'avais juste pas que ça faisait partie
de la saisine ça pour ça ok c'est cool
on apprend de nouvelles choses tous les
jours c'est quoi
oui je sais maintenant
bon du coup cette partie ça serait la
partie décisive j'imagine qu'il y aura
des trucs du genre qu eric baissus après
que c'est lui qui avait b6 ouais ça sera
nul ça ça absolument nulle ya ya pas
vraiment moyen de passer parce que si
les blancs essayer de faire des trucs du
genre et cas nécessitent y aura toujours
tout reprendre mes 5
ouais donc ça mange froid pas très très
bien
bien sûr là les blancs il aimerait bien
faire cette manoeuvre même et ça marche
pas pas du sureau toujours comme on a
dit safina tenter des trucs sur la loi
sur des lois mais les noirs bloc assez
facilement
bon elle se bat on fait et est fait de
le effet vraiment le mieux qu'elle peut
mais mais du coup je pense que ça serait
impossible mais me noir peuvent essayer
de pousser là avec cavalli détroit qui
avait f2 je pense qu'elle a trop essayé
ce marché le gain et du coup elle va se
retrouver à au moins bien des cas pays
ces deux cas bf2 c'est fou ça l a pas vu
à temps ici ici sur k et ses deux filles
avec a veillé tout simplement
elle a fait un coup trop tard elle la
tour a pu bouger entre temps oui mais à
riga aurait pu gagner tellement
facilement
ok donc c'est nul ça nul elle a vraiment
eu chaud
d'ailleurs je pense que la position
finale est avec toujours gagnante pour
les noirs même même sens tactique
donc là c'est juste des partis
classiques ça paraît que c'est pas la
mort subite donc
donc là je pense qu'ils vont faire ou
encore deux parties et après si c'est
encore nul je pense qu'ils vont faire
mort subite
parce que oui du coup là c'est pas il
joue juste des parties normales pour
rien n'est décisif
enfin tant qu'elle continue à faire
mieux donc là on veut bien faire déjà
des tours je dirais celui de 20,5 ça m'a
l'air pas mal
aussi la position des blanches malheur
pas mal aussi à mes idées décalées des
cas qui peuvent arriver aussi
ouais mais youku c'est en plus difficile
j'ai envie de pousser f4 mais ce n'était
pas facile parce que faut quand même
défendre ceux qui ont re 5
si on bouge le cavalier à ce moment-là y
aura un cahier pour les 5 oui en tout ça
sera 5 minutes oui dieu
ouais parce que du coup elles ont permis
aux ouvriers super un don montons pas
veut super longtemps vu que vu le nom de
parti qui elle joue moi ouais et aussi
en inde
je pense que il doit faire assez tard
mais bon ça je pense que ces parangons
facteurs parce qu'il fait pas si tard
que ça à mon avis en inde en inde
maintenant il fait les genres
il fait d'euros 28,9 je crois parce que
je crois qu'ils ont trente minutes de
moins que peuvent que nous ici c'est
d'ailleurs c'est mort d'alison juste
trente minutes de mon choix par une
oeuvre ici et chez moi il est il est
21h30 et aux consignes auquel à paris du
coup quand j'imagine elle doit être vue
quel bille à part lui j'imagine qu'elle
est à paris en ce moment du coup bon
ayant signé une toute petite différence
de donner mon sang chaud ça ne change
pas grand-chose du mali six as joué à 3h
du mat ça fait ça ça par contre ça ça
aurait des gros changements mais mes luc
serre le porto il n'y a pas de souci
bon c'est un beau coup sa fougue et 6
pour prendre ouais elle a gaffé l agcs
afrique autant qu elle a sacrément gaffé
un de sita alors je pense à 17,38 vidéo
ou un truc du genre parce que là du coup
je connais je je salue nos salles le nom
ça me dit quelque chose mais du coup je
connais pas trop la référence
wen la salle à salers fini ça a l'air
très difficile on peut dire qu'ils ont
là qu'il va tomber salaires mort de chez
moi après kb8 carrie voilà plein de
trucs sans notre musique hockey aa de
jouer le site à ok je connais pas du
coup là je vais je connaissais pas que
ces instruments bon ben brik est à
gagner
du coup c'est pas fini c'est pas fini
donc elle a juste davantage comme au
tennis elle doit avoir 40
il va avoir 40 soit annoncée à tangi
neuf mois soutenue ça se passe comment
ces 40 tonnes avantages qu'on reconduit
que c'est 40 et après la liane ses
avantages
je crois du coup c'est pareil mais si
elle trouve ça à 30
ça fait un bail que j'ai pas joué j'ai
oublié je crois que c'est 46 à 40
partout du coup ça avantage je crois ne
m'en voulez pas céline
du coup là j'aimerais bien faire des
trucs du genre à 4 pour empêcher les
baies 5 m et du coup elle n'a pas fait
beaucoup mais ça arrive si vite bécane
peut-être à 4 elle l'a fait mais c'est
un peu trop tard mais non mais ça ils du
coup là elle a eu la casse et 4 ça peut
être pas si mal
super non guitare qu'elle soit en dix
ans google les beatles au genre qu'elle
laquelle type dauphin du coup si tu sais
je j'ai réécouté ça genre le nom dedans
des noms des chansons
si tu connais
du coup là elle essaye d'avoir une
attaque sur la loi mais ça n'a pas l'air
de marcher je pense que le cavalière de
tout défendre et ça sera plutôt les
noirs qui vont ils vont chercher avec
reald des problèmes sur le pur eux
quatre
du coup ils poussent les pousse à écrire
noires elles poussent ouais comme on dit
là le pion aux 4 ou pas tant anouk et
j'ai pensé que je pensais que c'était au
nord de jeu elle pouvait faire faut
prendre des cartes maîtresses
donc ils attendent les camions
[Musique]
bah c'est marqué d'essai video is not
available
tyco j'ai pas le droit de voir une des
dans mon pays mais du coup c'est le web
cette vidéo je ne peux pas je peux pas
la quille est bizarre
huo la gaffe à bas du coup c'est harry
cac et gagne c'est fini harry qui a
gagné elle a gagné les deux parties du
coup elle a deux points puces du coup là
et la gagne c'est décisif à bali donc
bien joué arica donc c'était vraiment
tendu mais du coup un pilote
je pense qu'elle a dû avoir plus
d'endurance eux tous et aussi avec une
avantage psychologique
bon bah c'était des bonne partie du coup
juste pour rappeler sa selle et au
prochain apparemment donc voilà donc là
ce qu'on avait c'était aussi mieux qu'on
entre dans nos valises et c'est harry
cap qui a gagné donc le prochain match à
sera entre stefanova et des six corps et
donc ça serait aussi très intéressant et
ça sera demain donc ça sera demain à peu
près la même heure je vais vous dire ça
exactement
oui c'est à la même heure qu'aujourd'hui
donc vous pourrez regarder ça si si vous
avez envie de voir plus de ces deux
matches à gros suspens comme c'était
aujourd'hui
donc voilà donc tout plein de tout plein
de choses intéressantes aujourd'hui on a
aussi beaucoup appris sur ces sur geller
étouffé tous ces gens là donc
donc si je vais y aller regarder tout ça
après gahler fuhrmann tout ça c'est
surtout ça que j'ai appris donc voilà
donc voilà donc j'espère que vous avez
apprécié les commentaires
voilà donc je serai de retour demain
pour le match de stéphane aubin et je
regarderai aussi là je suis les beatles
merci pour pour le non je vais essayer
si tu pouvais me dire ok le titre c'est
ok donc du coup je vais je vais regarder
ça
bon bah du coup à demain à demain alors
bye